When an anomaly is first detected by an SCP
Foundation Field Agent, it’s up to the Foundation’s
Mobile Task Forces to tag and bag the impossible
entities before they can do any more harm.
Sometimes these retrievals are uneventful,
other times... not so much - especially when
they’re dealing with brutal forces of nature
like SCP - 096, also known as, The Shy Guy.
A creature that, from its very first interaction
with the Foundation, had a reputation for
being dangerous and needed to be feared.
A series of vague sightings and mysterious
disappearances up in the frosty mountains
of the Yukon first sparked the Foundation’s
interest. When they were certain that they
had an anomaly on their hands, two retrieval
teams - Zulu 9-A and Zulu 9-B - were dispatched
to secure and contain the entity. Zulu 9-A
took the lead in a heavy duty chopper, equipped
with .50 caliber GAU-19 Heavy Machine-Guns
and carrying an AT-4 Anti-Tank launcher. They
were prepared for anything - or so they thought
- as they established a visual on SCP - 096
while two clicks away from the target.
They couldn’t get a clear line of sight
on the creature, but it appeared to be stationary,
docile, and was making no attempt to flee.
Piece of cake, right? Little did they know
that SCP - 096 was just looking away from
them. If it was facing towards them, it’d
be a whole different horror story, as Zulu
9-A were about to find out.
The team landed their helicopter next to the
creature and were shocked to see that it was
completely naked, in spite of the subzero
temperatures all around them. The creature
was unnaturally thin, as though it’d been
starved for weeks, with bone-white skin and
unnaturally long limbs. The team guessed that
the creature’s arms must have been at least
1.5 metres long, but its docile nature and
insubstantial body mass gave the impression
that it wouldn’t prove too difficult to
contain. That is, until they saw its face.
Zulu 9-A’s Captain was the lone survivor
of the incident, as he was lucky enough to
be looking away when the creature turned towards
his team. The rest of the squad ended up staring
eye to eye with SCP - 096, and from that moment
on it wasn’t docile anymore. The creature
began to whimper, then cry, then sob uncontrollably
in a way that sounded eerily human. This sudden
change in temperament startled the rest of
Zulu 9-A and they opened fire on the creature.
Under the hail of gunfire, SCP - 096 entered
a murderous frenzy and began tearing into
the hapless squad of soldiers. While its flesh
and organs did seem to take damage as a result
of the barrage of .50 caliber rounds from
the helicopter mounted machine guns, its skeletal
structure remained intact and it continued
its onslaught, tearing the team limb from
limb even after they’d blown practically
all the flesh from the creature.
The AT-4 Anti-Tank launcher proved equally
ineffective at stopping SCP - 096 while it
was in attack mode, and it was only after
slaughtering the entire team that it returned
to its docile state. Nobody knows exactly
what the creature did to Zulu 9-A after the
gunfire started, but no trace of the team
was left behind.
Zulu 9-B touched down soon after, and with
a grave warning from the Captain not to look
at the creature’s face, they were finally
able to subdue it. A bag was placed over SCP
- 096’s face, which seemed to soothe it
enough to move it to a nearby Foundation facility.
Little did they know, they’d just obtained
one of the deadliest SCPs of all time, and
while it may have been under lock and key
for now, it seems inevitable that it would
get out and cause more violence and chaos.
Research and containment procedures for the
SCP - 096 were put under the command of Dr.
Dan, a senior researcher at the site. It was
his job to find out exactly what this being
was capable of, and the more he tested, the
more he realized that they were dealing with
something truly terrifying.
Disposable D-Class personnel were used to
figure out exactly what it was that caused
the creature to enter its attack mode. Just
as it had during the initial retrieval mission,
SCP - 096 went berserk when any of the attending
personnel saw its face. In this stage, it
would enter a period of considerable and unstoppable
distress for one to two minutes - covering
its face and wailing loudly. When the period
of distress ended, the creature would mercilessly
slaughter every D-Class that had seen its
face, and just like with Zulu 9-A, no trace
of their bodies would be left behind.
Dr. Dan was horrified and intrigued by this
phenomenon. The creature killed anyone that
saw its face directly, but could the same
be said for indirect depictions of the creature’s
face - such as images and videos? Dr. Dan
was desperate to find out.
More D-Class personnel were brought in to
test this, to frightening results. Dr. Dan
found that the creature did indeed still enter
attack mode when people saw pictures and videos
of SCP - 096’s face. The creature seemed
to have an innate sense of when people were
viewing these representations even when it
should have had no conceivable way of knowing.
It didn’t matter how far away or how many
barriers were in place between the viewer
and the creature, the attack mode would still
activate. And once it did, it seemed as though
nothing could stop the creature from hunting
down the one who saw its face.
With all of this new data, special containment
procedures were devised to keep the creature
safely under lock and key. Its cell was a
5 m x 5 m x 5 m airtight steel cube, fitted
with advanced pressure sensors and laser detectors
to ensure that SCP - 096 remained in its cell
without risking anyone having visual contact
with the creature’s face. All cameras and
video equipment were strictly forbidden, and
weekly checks for any cracks or holes in the
containment cell were mandatory. Of course,
none of this would stop the creature if anyone
somehow saw its face. In order to solve that
little problem, Dr. Dan would need to continue
his research.
To find a method of subverting the creature’s
deadly glance, they needed to know exactly
what they were dealing with - but how could
they, when even a glance at a photo or video
of the being meant certain death? A potential
solution was proposed - creating an artistic
representation of the creature’s face, something
that hadn’t yet been attempted. But how
would they achieve such a feat? Simple - they’d
procure a D-Class prisoner with some artistic
talent, and they found one who had been a
tattoo artist before becoming a Foundation
guinea pig.
Dr. Dan formulated an ingenious plan for keeping
this D-Class alive for long enough to accurately
draw an image of SCP - 096’s face: He would
be placed in a Bathysphere diving bell several
kilometers underwater, and tens of kilometers
away from the containment cell where the SCP
was being held. The D-Class was made to look
at a photograph of the creature’s face,
and then replicate that image in a pencil
sketch. Dr. Dan first confirmed that the creature’s
attack mode is only activated by the creature’s
face by having the D-Class look at a series
of photos of the SCP’s body parts one by
one, finally finishing with its face. The
D-Class began drawing and even remarked on
how creepy the SCP’s facial features were,
despite not knowing the deadly context.
Meanwhile, back in its containment cell SCP
- 096 sensed someone viewing its face, and
entered its inconsolable crying state followed
by its attack mode. It broke out of containment
easily, and began making a beeline for the
D-Class, traversing the miles between it and
its prey. The D-Class didn’t know it as
he locked the finished drawing into a separate,
autonomous submersible, but he was already
dead. As the drawing made its way up to a
researcher on the surface, SCP - 096 dived
into the water, and started swimming down
towards the artist. Minutes later, the bathysphere
was breached, and the D-Class was torn to
shreds.
SCP - 096 was recaptured without issue by
surface recovery team Foxtrot-303-A, and further
testing on the drawing showed that artistic
representations of SCP - 096’s face were
in fact harmless. From this experience, we
now know that the creature has a gaunt face
with totally white eyes, possibly indicating
blindness, and a grossly extended jaw. Nevertheless,
Dr. Dan was adamant that SCP - 096 was too
dangerous to be left alive, and requested
permission from the upper echelons of the
Foundation to terminate the creature by any
means necessary. However, the doctor’s request
would fall on deaf ears, until...
It all started with a seemingly innocent image.
(Use this image: http://scp-wiki.wdfiles.com/local--files/incident-096-1-a/G9zmJ.jpg)
While it’s now been redacted for your safety,
the black spec inside the yellow circle was
once a minuscule image of SCP - 096, taken
unknowingly in the 1990s by a semi-professional
mountaineer. One day, they were looking at
old photographs when his eyes passed over
the tiny spec without even noticing he had
seen anything. But SCP - 096 noticed, and
began entering its attack mode.
It tore through its steel containment unit
like tissue paper, causing the release of
a nerve agent that killed a number of attending
Foundation staff. The monster then fled the
base and began pursuing its prey, with Mobile
Task Force Tau-1 in hot pursuit. Dr. Oleksei,
who was helping to manage the site where the
SCP was contained, was in dismay over the
situation. Dr. Dan was out of the country
at the time, trying to discover more about
the creature’s origins. However, he did
leave the Mobile Task Force with a new secret
weapon against the rampaging Shy Guy… Project
SCRAMBLE.
SCRAMBLE were state of the art goggles featuring
a new technology created by Dr. Dan, which
- using artistic renditions of 096’s facial
features - could detect and scramble the features
of SCP - 096 into an unrecognizable form,
preventing the normally deadly effect of gazing
upon on its face. In theory, this would allow
MTF Tau-1 to engage safely with 096 once its
prey had been eliminated and bring it back
into containment. But disaster struck on two
fronts. First, the prey in question was located
in a population center, creating the potential
for a huge loss of life.
And the second bigger problem was that the
SCRAMBLE technology didn’t work, as stray
pixels of the creature’s face would reach
the eyes of the task force before the internal
microprocessor had time to scramble them.
The mission turned into a death sentence,
as SCP - 096 slaughtered almost the entire
task force, as well as a number of civilians
in town - including an infant and its entire
family. It was a monumental disaster, made
even worse by a final revelation: Dr. Dan
and Dr. Oleksei had themselves facilitated
the entire containment breach and allowed
the resulting massacre to happen, with Dr.
Dan hoping it would be enough motivation for
Foundation Command to green-light his research
into destroying the creature.
Anything that would give him the opportunity
to kill this thing would be worth the bloodshed.
His plan worked and the SCP Foundation saw
it his way, approving his request to neutralize
SCP - 096. However, success comes at a cost
for Dr. Dan. Once he figures out a way to
finally kill the creature, though done in
the line of duty, he himself will be terminated
by the Foundation for his crimes against humanity.
But considering how much damage SCP - 096
is capable of causing if it ever got to a
major population center, or - even worse - was
ever caught on camera and broadcast to a worldwide
audience, the doctor himself would likely
deem his own death a justifiable cost. To
this day, the Foundation is researching ways
to kill the creature, and they’re still
looking for their silver bullet. And the pressure
is on. They hadn’t known about the seemingly
innocent picture that sparked the last containment
breach. The one taken decades ago, in which
the Shy Guy had only occupied four tiny pixels.
Four tiny pixels that resulted in multiple
innocent lives lost.
So be careful where you look because who knows
how many other photos of the creature are
lurking out there, photos with an innocent
dot in the background. Your eyes glance over
it, not even noticing the little blip, until
you hear a distant wailing that seems to be
getting closer, and closer, and closer. And
then... it’s already too late.
Well hello there, SCP Fans! Let’s get this
out of the way first - You’ve seen the title
and thumbnail, and you’re probably wondering:
Wait, is Siren Head an SCP? And the answer
is No. Siren Head is not an SCP, it’s a
freaky internet monster created by renowned
Canadian Horror Artist Trevor Henderson.
Your next question is probably: What’s with
this crazy-looking server bank behind me?
Allow me to introduce you to the Anom-O-Tron
6000, the latest advancement of supercomputing
owned and operated exclusively by the SCP
Foundation. It’s capable of a whole bunch
of interesting features - calculating ideal
containment methods, running state of the
art Foundation webcrawler software, making
and editing fun SCP YouTube videos - but the
most interesting feature that the Anom-O-Tron
has to offer is running hyper-advanced simulations
regarding all things anomalous, with data
fed into it by thousands of real-life experiments
conducted by the SCP Foundation.
It’s going to save countless dollars and
lives for Foundation researchers, but way
more importantly, it’s going to let us explore
all kinds of weird and wacky What If scenarios
that would never happen organically. Could
SCP-343 beat Goku, or Superman? Who’s a
deadlier supernatural killer, SCP-106 or Freddy
Kreuger? Would the world simply explode from
adorableness if SCP-999 and Baby Yoda ever
crossed those multiversal barriers and met?
We can explore all of these questions - Along
with any others you may have down in the comments.
Seriously, comment it. We dare you! - but
to get things started, we figured we’d make
the Anom-O-Tron pit the Foundation’s lankiest
nightmare monster, SCP-096, against the internet’s
- Trevor Henderson’s Siren Head.
Sorry, Slender Man, you’re just not cool
anymore.
So, without further adieu, let’s kick the
Anom-O-Tron into gear and see how this wild
battle plays out. It’s time for SCP-096
Vs Siren Head!
Ricky and Eliot, a pair of aspiring travel
YouTubers from California, were taking a vacation
to the Pacific Northwest to spend some time
in the area’s beautiful, lush forests. However,
while the duo were both big fans of travel
for its own sake, they weren’t just here
for the trees and fresh air. You see, despite
their jetsetting lifestyle, Ricky and Eliot’s
subscribers and views hadn’t exactly been
phenomenal lately. Turns out, hiking vlogs
and GoPro footage of the two of them jumping
into absurdly blue water in Bali weren’t
exactly that interesting to people who weren’t
actually there.
But Ricky had formulated an ingenious plan
to pull the two of them out of obscurity.
They would hunt down and film real footage
of the legendary Siren Head, a supernatural
monster said to haunt forests and isolated
graveyards. There were plenty of fakers out
there on YouTube, but if the two of them could
get real footage of Siren Head - and also,
preferably, survive the experience - they’d
be framing their Golden Play Buttons in no
time.
But they were already encountering certain
issues. For starters, the two Californians
had severely underestimated just how cold
it was in the Pacific Northwest, and as such,
were already shivering from bone-deep cold.
The second issue was food: While the two of
them had thought ahead and brought a selection
of tasty protein bars, they’d also gotten
hungry during the early hours of their walk,
and eaten all of them, leaving them feeling
severely out of luck by the time dinner rolled
around.
And the third and perhaps most problematic
issue of all was the fact that Ricky and Eliot
didn’t exactly have a great sense of direction.
During all of their previous trips, they’d
been on guided tours with local experts. In
this instance, wanting to take all the Siren
Head glory and clout for themselves, they’d
decided to come in alone, with the incredibly
janky Google Maps app to guide them. As such,
as the night was creeping in, the two aspiring
YouTube celebrities had no idea where they
were.
Needless to say, it wasn’t exactly an ideal
situation.
And to make matters worse, Ricky and Eliot
had been experiencing some strange feelings
for the last couple of hours, when they’d
gotten particularly deep into the forest.
That dread-inducing sensation of being watched
by something lurking just out of sight. A
gaze with some unknowable and darkly malicious
intent boiling behind it. These two poor saps
had no idea what was in store for them tonight,
and wouldn’t you know it, the one watching
them right now wouldn’t even be the only
monster after them.
After an expectable amount of bumbling and
buffoonery, Ricky and Eliot managed to gather
up enough tinder to make a semi-respectable
campfire. They could sleep out here tonight,
then set off in search of Siren Head or civilization
- whichever came first - in the daylight the
next day. The duo did what they could to remain
chipper, in spite of the ominous circumstances.
Sure, they were trapped in the depths of the
woods, alone, but think of the amazing vlog
footage they’d get!
They’d be like the next Blair Witch crew,
except they’d live, hopefully!
But as the duo sat next to their campfire,
they felt that ominous sensation again. The
hairs on the back of their necks started standing
up. They felt shivers that didn’t just come
from the cold. More and more, they started
to feel certain that something in this forest
was watching them. Something ancient and powerful
and evil. That’s when one of them heard
the telltale crackle of radio static, and
their skeletons almost jumped out of their
skin.
Could it be him? The Patron Saint of Going
Missing Without a Trace, of Creeping Dread,
of Bad Things Coming? Siren Head himself?
Both men fell silent. All they could hear
was the crackling of their own fire. Had the
sound before just been an illusion? A product
of a pair of paranoid minds also predisposed
to sense Siren-Headed monsters lurking amongst
the trees? They’d been reading about a higher
rate of disappearances in this area, along
with a number of frightening sightings of
tall, thin beings and radio static that seemed
perfectly consistent with Siren Head activity.
That’s why they’d come here in the first
place. But had they come here to their deaths?
The two needed to distract themselves or they’d
go mad from the paranoia. They decided to
share a few fun little anecdotes of the travels
they’d had before meeting one another, showing
the photos they’d saved on their smartphones.
Ricky had been to Hawaii, Tahiti, Bora Bora,
Fiji, St. Lucia, and the Maldives. Clearly,
he liked his vacations warm and sandy. Eliot,
on the other hand, tended to like his trips
to be a little more adventurous. He’d seen
volcanoes, waterfalls, deep and treacherous
cave systems, and of course, a little guided
mountaineering.
One photo that Eliot showed Ricky was particularly
breathtaking: He was standing in the foreground
of a snowy landscape, with an incredible mountain
range behind him. When Ricky asked Eliot where
exactly he’d taken this picture, strangely
enough, he drew a complete blank. Maybe somewhere
in Canada, or Siberia, or something like that…
But it was a hell of a trip, whatever the
case, he remembered having a great time.
It was such a tiny detail, but when looking
at the photo, Ricky couldn’t help but notice
something in the background. A speck of white.
Sure, not exactly newsworthy in a snowy mountain
range, but this wasn’t snow. It was a speck
of white that seemed to be a slightly different
shade than the rest of the mountain. Strange.
Perhaps it was just some tiny particle stuck
on the lens whenever the photo was taken.
The two continued to chat and warm their hands
against the fire, having no idea of the horror
they’d just awoken in doing so.
Over a hundred miles away, at an SCP Foundation
containment site, researchers and guards walked
around the perimeter of a huge, airtight metal
cube, reading off diagnostics and audio recordings.
For reasons that should be obvious to everyone
who’s a fan of this channel, there were
no camera feeds coming from the inside of
the great metal cube. Only a faint whimpering
sound, like a sad, wounded animal, and the
clanking of pacing feet moving back and forth
over the metal, dragging forlorn knuckles.
It turned every head in the room when the
crying started to get louder. Soon, it wasn’t
just quiet weeping, it was a series of horrendous,
slobbering sobs, wails of pure pain and despair.
Someone in the room screamed “Close your
eyes and hit the deck!”, knowing exactly
what had happened. They’d learned well enough
from the infamous Incident 096-1-A Containment
Breach that there was no way of stopping this
thing until it’d run its course. The best
they could do was minimize their own fatalities
in the process.
Everyone in the room did as they were told,
hitting the ground, closing their eyes, and
covering them with their hands, just to be
safe. That’s when the solid steel of the
cube was torn open like crepe paper, and the
howling, raging SCP-096 broke free, galloping
on all fours through the nearest wall, shattering
it and spraying debris everywhere.
As Mobile Task Forces were dispatched to track
the rampaging abomination and try their best
to clear the path ahead as it sought out its
target, one thought was going through the
minds of everyone in the room: “Woe betide
the poor fools who saw that monster’s face…”
Back in the deep, dark forests of the Pacific
Northwest, the presence of some unnerving
force was becoming far harder to deny for
Ricky and Eliot. They heard the sounds of
garbled voices out in the woods. The squeals
and crackles of radio static. They saw shapes
moving amongst the trees, tall and thin, like
long, spindly limbs. While neither wanted
to voice their fear, they were both thinking
similar things: If there really was a monster
out here, why hadn’t it killed them? It
had all the time in the world to do it.
But that was just it, wasn’t it? It had
all the time in the world, so why rush? It
had every advantage. It could take its time,
and do this exactly how it wanted to. Ricky
and Eliot had made themselves the perfect
prey. And as they saw a huge, lithe figure
suddenly separate itself from the trees, they
began to wonder if it was really worth it
to risk both of their lives for YouTube clout.
Either way, it was now probably too late for
regrets.
Ricky and Eliot’s jaws fell in horror as
the monster emerged from the darkness before
them. They recognized the awful, mottled skin
stretched over the monster’s forty-foot
frame. They saw the grasping hands, and up
above, the nightmarish, faceless head, split
into a pair of sirens pointing in different
directions, each one filled with gnashing
teeth and slithering tongues. It was even
more terrifying than they possibly could have
imagined.
Siren Head’s speakers crackled into life,
and hissed out, “NINE. EIGHTEEN. ONE. CHILD.
SEVENTEEN. REMOVE. VILE.”
Ricky and Eliot stumbled backwards as Siren
Head advanced, its speakers still bleeding
hateful static. Neither could move or speak,
only watch as its long, gnarled fingers reached
from the dark to grasp them.
There was a terrible pained wail in the woods
after that. But it wasn’t coming from Ricky,
Eliot, or Siren Head. It was distant at first,
but soon became louder and louder as the force’s
point of origin came barreling towards them.
Even Siren Head couldn’t help but turn to
see SCP-096, a flash of terrible white fury,
come charging towards them in the dark, knowing
down all the trees in its path. Leaves and
pine needles scattered. Trunks exploded into
splinters. Nothing would stop the Shy Guy
from claiming its prey. Nothing would stop
it from destroying Ricky, and now, as it approached,
Eliot made the fatal mistake of looking at
its face, too.
096 lunged, ready to go in for the kill, when
Siren Head’s hands closed around the Shy
Guy’s slender torso. In one fluid motion,
with surprising strength for its scrawny build,
it hurled the Shy Guy into the distance, smashing
another several trees in its path.
The words, “MY PREY. MY PREY. MINE. MINE.
MINE,” hissed out of its speakers.
But 096 was only down for mere moments. It
sprung back up on its hind and forelegs and
started galloping towards Ricky and Eliot
again, who were still frozen in place. This
time, just before the Shy Guy’s terrible
claws could close around the two hapless wannabe
YouTubers, down came Siren Head’s clenched
fist, pounding 096’s head into the dirt.
Overhead, Mobile Task Force helicopters circled,
wearing their SCRAMBLE goggles and trying
to get a visual on the situation unfolding
below. They could hardly believe what they
were seeing down there. Was some other unclassified
anomaly managing to intercept SCP-096 in its
rage state? Only a handful of anomalies on
record had ever been shown as being capable
of such a feat. It seemed they were dealing
with something serious here.
Down below, the battle continued. Siren Head
had a unique advantage over most other combatants
facing SCP-096: It was an extradimensional
being with no eyes, merely an innate psychic
awareness of its victims around it - not unlike
how SCP-096 detects people seeing its face
in photographs or videos without need for
any kind of direct contact. As such, it was
impossible for Siren Head to see the Shy Guy’s
face, and thus, impossible for the Shy Guy
to ever actually direct its aggression against
it.
Whether or not 096 would kill-steal Siren
Head’s intended prey was another matter
entirely.
In the night’s first minor miracle, Ricky
and Eliot remembered that they’d been born
with working legs, and decided that right
now would be an excellent time to use them.
They turned and began to run while Siren Head
continued beating the Shy Guy into the dirt,
sprinting with all their might. However, the
growing distance between them only aggravated
the Shy Guy further.
It sprang out from the dirt with unstoppable
force and broke away from Siren Head’s grip.
The Shy Guy never wasted time, ever, it always
made a beeline for its intended victim with
one directive in mind: Total annihilation.
Tonight is no different. Ricky and Eliot screamed
as they heard its pounding gallop on the ground
behind them.
Closer, closer, closer…
Then suddenly, defying all spatial reasoning,
Siren Head emerged out of the darkness between
Ricky, Eliot, and 096. Being forty feet tall,
Siren Head dwarfed even the Shy Guy. It lunged
and grabbed the wailing white monstrosity,
holding it as one would a particulary vicious
cat and trying to keep it in place. Siren
Head wanted to crush this monster’s bones
and carry on stalking its feeble human prey
- who were currently in the process of getting
away - but somehow, that was impossible.
It was almost like the monster had an indestructible
skeleton…
Up above, the Mobile Task Forces continued
observing this clash of the titans from their
two helicopters. Seeing how Siren Head was
somehow doing a serviceable job of subduing
the Shy Guy, one of the task force members
joked, “Maybe we should hire this guy.”
Another chimed in, “I don’t think we have
any ballistic vests in his size.”
The laughter soon turned to screams when Siren
Head hurled SCP-096’s flailing body up at
one of the helicopters with incredible force,
knocking it out of the sky. It careened down
to the ground, a ball of fear and violence,
before exploding. Anyone who survived the
initial blast was unlucky enough to have seen
the Shy Guy’s face. Their screams rang out,
briefly, before being abruptly silenced by
the monster. Helicopter Alpha had no survivors.
Meanwhile, Ricky and Eliot had kept running
until their lungs burned and their muscles
pumped thumbtacks. Seeing that the chaos was
so far behind them now, they took a moment
to stop and breathe, recomposing themselves.
In the second minor miracle of the night,
it looked like the two of them had actually
survived this ordeal. Those two horrific monsters
had canceled each other out.
But Ricky and Eliot were about to learn a
harsh lesson: They really weren’t that lucky.
The last thing the two ever saw was Siren
Head emerging from the darkness once more.
The last thing they ever felt was the monster’s
terrible, gnarled fingers curling around their
bodies, too fast for them to escape. And the
last thing they ever heard was each other’s
screams, followed by a sickeningly meaty crunch.
Elsewhere in the forest, SCP-096’s wails
died down to its usual maudlin sob. The rage
state had ended; all of its targets had been
destroyed. It just hadn’t been the one to
do all of the destroying, per se.
Not long after that, Helicopter Bravo descended
safely and the remaining MTF members closed
around the blubbering beast. Someone black
bagged it and everyone breathed a sigh of
relief, knowing that was at least one monster
taken care of tonight.
“What about the other one?” the MTF Lieutenant
asked.
The team’s commander shook his head and
said, “Let’s worry about that freak later
and get 096 back to containment. This place
gives me the creeps…”
This video is about two things: The first
is SCP – 096, also known as The Shy Guy,
a horrific monster who murders anyone and
anything unfortunate enough to look at its
face, directly or through photos or videos.
The second is you – because we asked you
for your favourite questions, theories, and
hypothetical situations involving 096. We
even asked you if you thought someone would
be safe from 096 on the moon, and you delivered.
If you haven’t watched our first video on
the infamous Shy Guy, we recommend checking
that out first, but feel free to stick around
even if you haven’t.
First of all, let’s take a look at the questions
you had about the SCP Foundation’s most
dangerous introvert, and see if we can find
some answers.
“How close would you have to be to trigger
it? Like, if it was 5km away, would it still
count?”
The short answer is that 096’s homicidal
rage can be triggered from pretty much any
distance. We’ll get into some of the potentially
crazy extents of this later on, but if you
see the Shy Guy’s face while you’re sharing
a dimension with him, you’re in serious
trouble. People who’ve viewed the creature’s
face in different countries, or even miles
underwater have met gruesome ends 5 kilometers
would definitely not keep you safe.
“What were his origins and how strong is
he compared to SCP-682?”
The origins of SCP – 096 are still shrouded
in mystery – all we know for sure is that
he was discovered by the Foundation in a snowy,
mountainous region. As for physical durability,
he’s about even with 682 as both survived
their encounter. We know 682 has the psychological
advantage though, as 096 has been terrified
of the lizard ever since they met in cross
testing. However, you could argue that 096
is technically more dangerous, since unlike
682, 096 has never been pacified before killing
its intended target while on a rampage.
“If he goes into an "unstoppable attack
mode" when someone sees his face, shouldn’t
you NOT show his face in the thumbnail?
Thankfully, according to the official documents,
artistic representations, like paintings or
digitally-drawn YouTube thumbnails have no
effect. Only actual photographs or videos
of the creature can be deadly, so you’re
safe – unless we decide to do an 096 Face
Reveal to celebrate our next 100,000 subscribers,
of course. This leads into our next question.
“If it attacks you when you look at it,
then how did the scientist draw the picture
of the thing without looking at it?”
That’s a good question, and also one that
occurred to the Foundation scientists, who
came up with an extremely elaborate solution.
They put a D-Class tattoo artist inside a
diving bell miles underwater, and had him
unseal a photograph of the creature before
drawing a copy. This copy was then released
from the diving bell in a sealed container,
before 096 inevitably got to the poor D-Class.
“Does the shy guy have to be viewed through
a good quality image to enter a rage state?”
Unfortunately no, even the most poorly rendered
or miniscule image of 096’s face is a death
sentence. One of the most infamous incidents
resulted from a man seeing a small dot that
was only a few pixels wide in a photo from
an old ski trip. This dot was 096, taken from
a mile away. No true image of 096 is safe,
regardless of size.
“In some canons, despite 096 being referred
to as indestructible, the Foundation managed
to terminate it after many attempts and even
more bureaucracy. How did they do it?”
While a lot of 096’s body has been blown
away by conventional arms fire, its hyper-tough
skeleton is what has given it such an indestructible
reputation. In one tale though, Foundation
researchers actually used this to their advantage,
and employed the use of the neck-snapping
killer sculpture, SCP-173. After using 173
to damage 096’s bones, powerful acid was
injected into the skeleton, destroying it
from within. Though of course, this isn’t
the official ending of the 096 story, because
the SCP Foundation doesn’t have a single
unifying canon.
That’s enough questions. Now, it’s time
for you to school us – let’s look at some
of your favorite theories about the Shy Guy.
Starting with…
“I sometimes like to imagine that 096 is
nice, but he can’t control when someone
sees him and after he kills the person he
starts to cry because he didn’t want to
kill them.”
There is actually some evidence to suggest
that SCP – 096 might not want to kill. A
great example is its cross test with SCP – 978,
a camera which reveals the deepest desires
of whoever or whatever is in its photos. The
photo it took of 096 showed that it had completely
disappeared from the photo – showing its
deepest desire was just to be invisible and
unseen. Maybe it wants to disappear because
it doesn’t want to hurt anybody?
“Regarding the Moon question, I think SCP-096
would probably stay in that hostile state
until you came back, at which point it would
promptly rip you to shreds and do whatever
it does to your mutilated corpse”
Based on what we know about prior 096 incidents,
this feels incredibly likely. It’s also
possible that it might enter its docile state,
before becoming aggressive again when you
return to its murder range. You really don’t
want to find out, either way.
“He can jump to the moon easy, he does squats
in containment all the time.”
While its scrawny physique doesn’t make
it seem like 096 understands the concept of
exercise, there aren’t any cameras in 096’s
cell – so technically, we can’t prove
it isn’t doing squats to pass the time in
there.
“I really doubt a blind person would be
safe from his effect, since 096 has the IQ
of a new born baby, I think he will count
it as looking at him”
This is an interesting theory. However, seeing
as 096 is able to sense when people see its
face from entire continents away, the way
it knows if you can see its face might be
a little more psychic in nature. Therefore,
it’s probable that it wouldn’t mistakenly
kill someone who hasn’t actually seen its
face – such as a person who is blind.
“To deal with him in my opinion… simply
freeze him. Either in space or the mountains.
His body shuts down and when looked at it
will not react correctly. It is simply asleep.”
While we don’t know how SCP – 096 would
react to a zero-g environment, for a creature
that’s always nude, it seems extremely tolerant
to the cold. When it was first found, it was
lurking in icy mountains and a Foundation
agent commented on the fact it wasn’t even
shivering, despite the incredibly low temperatures.
But who knows if there’s a temperature out
there that’s too low even for the Shy Guy?
“If someone looks at it in China and it’s
the US, then you get on its back, you’ll
get a free piggy back ride to China. It’s
a free trip to China, and all it costs is
a human life. That’s my theory”
Technically, it’d be at the cost of two
human lives, unless you wore a diving suit
with plenty of Oxygen. 096 has proven to be
an extremely proficient swimmer, but you’d
have to maintain your grip across the entire
Pacific Ocean while it journeys to China.
In other words, it’s technically possible,
but we here at SCP Explained would rather
pay for the roundtrip flight. To each their
own though.
But that’s enough theories for now. Let’s
move on to the main event: Hypotheticals.
You posed some great possible scenarios involving
SCP – 096, so we’re going to see if we
can find the answers.
“What would happen if someone looked at
a picture of it while in or before entering
another SCP’s pocket dimension or mirror
dimension?”
There aren’t any canon examples to prove
either way, but if there’s any kind of consistent
entry point into this dimension, it’s likely
that 096 would find a way to follow you in.
If not, it’s very possible that it may just
wait for you to eventually return, before
bringing the metaphorical hammer down on you.
So technically, if you were pulled into the
Old Man’s pocket dimension and he closed
the portal, you’d be safe from 096, but
then you’ve got a whole other problem to
deal with.
[ANIMATION NOTE: Hypothetical proposed by
“😊”]
“What happens if a person sees his face
then gets their memory of the creature wiped?”
Considering how good the Foundation seems
to be at wiping people’s memories and their
access to amnestics, if this worked, they
probably would have made it standard procedure
by now – so it’s unlikely.
“What happens if a person looked at it and
the person then went on a plane? Or just staying
in the air or space what would it do?”
096 has shown the ability to jump up and destroy
low-flying aircraft, but otherwise, it’s
likely that the creature would probably run
to a point directly below you and remain there
until you touched back down. Since you’ll
need food and water at some point and aircrafts
need fuel, you’d probably just be prolonging
the inevitable.
“What if the young girl was around it so
it tried to attack her but died trying?”
This is another interesting possibility. SCP-053
is a girl capable of causing homicidal urges,
but causes fatal heart attacks in those who
attack her. While we can’t know for sure
how a meeting between 096 and 053 would go,
we can use her encounter with 682 as a potential
template. Aggressive SCPs like the hard to
kill reptile, perhaps having an innate knowledge
of the danger that comes from attacking 053,
tend to become strangely docile around her.
It’s possible that 096 would do the same.
“Would we be able to control SCP-096 with
the help of SCP-035?”
The Possessive Mask, aka SCP – 035, is undeniably
a lot more intelligent than 096, and has even
been shown to respond to reason on occasion.
It’s also been able to control almost every
other entity it’s been placed on. The problem
is, if the Mask was placed on 096, and it
was somehow effective, the result may be even
more dangerous than 096 – An intelligent
monster with an indestructible and highly
dangerous body. There’s no telling whether
035 would slowly break down 096 into sludge
the way it does to humans, in which case we
could be left with an immortal 096 - 035 combo.
So maybe it’s best that we never find out.
“If someone were to be in the infinite Ikea,
and looked at a picture of its face, could
it be finally contained, and if someone else
looked at a picture of it outside of the Infinite
Ikea, could it escape and kill them, if so,
how long would it take it?”
This is a great question, and while the infinite
ikea is a terrifying maze, SCP -096 has an
advantage here that we don’t: Not only can
it rip through anything in the way with its
super strength, it has an innate sense of
where its victim is. Therefore, regardless
of whether you’re inside and out, SCP -096
will still come straight to you to exact your
horrible fate.
But at least you can enjoy the meatballs while
you wait, right?
And finally:
“What would happen if 096 were led into
a room full of mirrors and allowed or made
to look at its own face? Would it smash the
mirrors or try to rip itself to pieces?”
This is still a hotly debated issue to this
day, which – thanks to the “no canon”
nature of the SCP Foundation – doesn’t
have a definitive answer. Some theorize that
this would at least be an effective deterrent
against SCP – 096, while others suggest
that it wouldn’t be effective, because many
believe that 096 is actually blind and thus
cannot see its own face. It can only sense
when other people see it. Again, we don’t
quite know for sure, but it’s likely to
remain one of the most contentious issues
around the Shy Guy for a long time to come.
What does a monster look like to you? What
figures slither and claw their way into your
nightmares, chasing you down endless halls
and stalking you through the dark until you
wake up screaming?
Maybe you imagine something tall and lean,
bony arms reaching for you from atop impossibly
long, slender legs, its featureless face showing
no mercy. Maybe you think of a man in a striped
sweater with knives for fingers, or a serial
killer in a hockey mask, wielding a machete.
Maybe it’s something more inhuman, a cosmic
horror of tentacles and eyes that can see
into your very soul. You probably don’t
think of something with no arms, no legs,
no body at all. Just a face.
What’s so scary about that?
A face can’t run after you, can’t grab
you by the ankles and pull you under the bed.
A face can only look. It may be unsettling
to behold, it might send a chill down your
spine, but the worst it can do is make you
a little uncomfortable. And if you can’t
stand it any longer, you could always just
close your eyes, or walk away and be done
with it.
Right?
If that’s what you think, if you don’t
believe in monsters that can hurt you without
lifting a finger, then you’re the type to
fall victim to a very special, very intelligent
mask.
In the hallowed halls of the SCP Foundation,
there is a containment cell outfitted with
a hermetically sealed glass case, surrounded
by steel, iron, and lead. There are guards
posted outside, along with a trained psychologist.
If you are ever brave, and foolish, enough
to enter that room, you’ll see a simple
white porcelain comedy mask, with a peculiar
black substance leaking from its eyes and
mouth.
Wherever this slime touches, surfaces begin
to corrode, to rot away into puddles of black
liquid. You might notice the same liquid trickling
slowly down the walls of the room, corrupting
everything in its path. As unsettling of a
sight as it is, if you approach the mask to
take a closer look, you will find yourself
overcome by an intense, nearly irresistible
urge to pick it up, and put it on. To wear
it, to let it consume you from the inside
out and puppet your body while your brain
simply…turns off.
Like an extinguished flame, you’ll simply
be gone. Then, who knows what the mask will
do? It won’t be your concern anymore, that’s
for sure.
But thankfully, you haven’t gone into the
room with the porcelain mask. You haven’t
let it cast its spell on you. Not yet, at
least. It’s waiting for you there, in the
room with black slime oozing down its walls.
And it will wait patiently, for as long as
it needs to.
After all, what’s a mask without a face
to wear it?
SCP-035, better known as the Possessive Mask,
sat in its containment cell, immobile as always.
It didn’t really have much of a choice in
the matter. The Foundation had chosen, selfishly,
to revoke its host privileges. Once upon a
time, they had offered it bodies to choose
from, mannequins, dummies, and wooden dolls
it could adorn and pilot. They didn’t last
as long as an organic, living host, of course.
But it was something. It was a taste of freedom.
This dreadful new situation was almost enough
to make the mask want to change its expression
from comedy to tragedy, but it was determined
to still find something to laugh about.
Even without a body, trapped in this infernal
box, there had been some delicious opportunities
for entertainment. Human minds were fragile
things. The mask had learned this over the
infinite years of its life, if one could call
it a life. Apply the right kind of pressure
to the right weak points, whisper an enticing
word or two, find the right emotional wound
to sprinkle a pinch of salt into, and humans
would buckle completely in almost no time
at all.
It had tried all sorts of methods since being
confined to this boring little box. Sometimes
it would charm someone, pour honeyed flattery
into their heads until the person felt like
the mask was a dear friend, a confidante.
Once suitable trust had been built up, the
mask could persuade the person to bring it
a host, or perhaps even offer up themselves
in sacrifice. If flattery didn’t work, there
were other potent approaches to take.
For a being without ears, the mask was a good
listener. It picked up on things that no human
ever could, the darkest secrets buried in
a person’s mind. If it caught wind of something
especially juicy and ruinous, it could leverage
that. Threaten to expose an affair, a crime,
or perhaps something even worse. Something
unspeakable. If praise failed, and so did
blackmail, there was always good old supernatural
intimidation. All the mask needed was for
someone to be left alone with it for a long
enough period of time. Then, its invisible
tendrils could snake out into their defenseless
mind, weaving and poking around, leaving a
lingering sense of cold, dread, of incomprehensible
whispers in long-dead tongues.
What a delight containment had been in the
early days, when the Foundation had not yet
figured out the mask’s true capabilities.
When they would leave security personnel with
weak wills and minimal training standing guard
in the mask’s field of influence for hours
at a time, as the entity played with their
thoughts and chipped away at their free will.
It had almost escaped more than once, thanks
to the helpers it had been able to mold out
of those hapless victims. They had been there
to break open its case and carry it to freedom.
But every time, the other guards thwarted
the attempts, shooting its helpers and rendering
them utterly useless.
Then, the Foundation increased its security.
Something about the unacceptably high suicide
and homicide rates among staff assigned to
SCP-035. How utterly boring. How truly…pathetic.
Still, the mask had found ways to occupy itself
even without any more playthings. It had grown
stronger with its boredom, stretching its
influence beyond organic beings and into the
very room itself, its evil enriching and deepening
like a fine wine in the depths of a cold cellar.
Over the months, the walls of SCP-035’s
containment cell had begun to secrete the
same black, slimy substance that would pour
from the mask’s eyes and mouth. The liquid
dripped down the walls in deliberate formations,
patterns that became increasingly easy to
recognize. Phrases in Italian, Latin, Ancient
Greek, all detailing ritual sacrifices and
mutilations. The mask took time to describe
the sacrificial victims in great detail, borrowing
identifying traits from various staff members
that it knew would read the translations.
The walls were slick with blood and harrowing
imagery, and the glass case around the mask
was growing more and more fragile by the day.
Anyone within 10 meters of the mask could
feel this strength, too. They would leave
the area complaining of unintelligible whispers,
of loud, cruel laughter, and a lingering sense
of nearly insurmountable despair. It was as
if they knew, on some level, that no one was
truly safe.
Eventually, the mask would find a way to come
for them all. The glass was weakening, and
soon the mere thought of escape would make
it shatter into pieces. Then, perhaps, the
mask could finally get its deepest desire:
revenge. It wanted nothing more than to make
the Foundation pay for imprisoning it, for
taking away its host privileges, for trying
harder and harder to contain the kind of power
that should have had them falling to their
knees in worship. The mask seethed with hatred
day in and day out. It had seen the crumbling
of the Roman Empire, the beheading of kings,
the decimation of armies. It was not going
to be captured by a bunch of rats in lab coats
without dire consequences befalling them.
Maybe it couldn’t move from its prison cell
at the moment, but it also knew that it was
surrounded on all sides by dangerous beasts
capable of reducing the site, and all who
had dared to oppose the mask, to a pile of
smoldering rubble. If it could only find its
way onto one of their faces…it would show
them all just what it was capable of. As the
piercing sound of an alarm echoed down the
hall, the sound of screams and chaos following
shortly after, the mask’s frowning face
curved into a broad, menacing smile.
What was it that had escaped? The lizard,
perhaps? The giant, grinning man? Whatever
it was, it seemed that the action was heading
right toward 035’s containment cell. Perhaps
today was the day. Finally, the SCP Foundation
would fall.
Outside the mask’s cell, Security Officer
Harper was running for dear life. Though his
more rational mind knew he was living on seconds,
not even minutes, of borrowed time, his animal
brain kept his legs pumping - desperately
trying to avoid the screaming, howling predator
hot on his heels.
Harper looked over his shoulder and screamed
as a long, white arm reached for him. SCP-096:
The Shy Guy, its tooth-lined jaw hanging low
and foaming with spittle. That face, that
terrible, terrible face - an absolute death
sentence to all who saw it. He’d seen what
he thought was a crack in the otherwise perfect
seal of 096’s containment chamber, but it
could have just as easily been a trick of
the light.
Not even thinking, he’d stepped forward
and looked at the vulnerability in the chamber.
All it took was one misplaced ray of light,
and he made out the vague shape of a face
in the darkness. That’s when the weeping
started. Harper knew, in that moment, his
life was over. The correct thing to do would
have been to order everyone else in the room
to close their eyes while he stood there and
accepted his fate, minimizing the risk of
spreading the damage further. But humans rarely
have perfect reasoning, even less so when
facing mortality.
Back in the present, the Shy Guy made a perfect
lunge, grabbing Harper in its iron clutches
and barreling through the adjoining wall.
The nearby guards scattered, terrified, keeping
their eyes on the floor. They might get a
slap on the wrist for temporarily abandoning
their posts, but they weren’t going to die
guarding some stupid evil mask.
Speaking of, the possessive mask was surprised
to feel two new presences enter its chamber
- through the now-destroyed wall. These two
presences soon became just one, as SCP-096
quickly and totally annihilated Security Officer
Harper, leaving nothing left. The mask couldn’t
see, per se, seeing as it had no actual sensory
organs, but it felt around this new guest
with its many psychic tendrils, taking in
its strange totality.
The creature was powerful, no doubt about
that, and it elicited fear from those fools
at the SCP Foundation, but the mask noticed
its brainwaves were extraordinarily muted.
Humans, to the mask’s vast and malicious
consciousness, weren’t the sharpest knives
in the drawer, but compared to this thing’s
mind, they were a pile of tempered katanas.
It barely thought at all. The mask would have
to dig deeper to find anything it could use…
Meanwhile, SCP-096 finally began to calm down.
The one who had seen it had been annihilated.
Bubbling rage was slowly siphoned out and
replaced by the standard low but constant
hum of anxiety and despair. It would simply
wait until its head was bagged and it was
dragged back to the dark. Same old, same old,
all the way to the end of time. That’s when
it felt something else. It started as a faint
buzz, an unintelligible whisper. Then, it
was almost like a door opened in the back
of its head, Something stepped in and took
a seat.
Can you hear me, stranger? Knock knock. I
want to speak to you…
Something about the voice frightened and comforted
SCP-096 at the same time. It spoke with a
greater degree of sympathy than the creature
had heard in a long time, and yet, something
about the way it spoke implied evil in its
intent.
I know what you want. I know what you fear.
Wouldn’t it be nice if they could never
look at you again? If you could cover that
face of yours? I can help you. It will be
so simple. All you need to do is put me on…
Little by little, 096 felt more of these strange
thoughts filling up the emptiness in its head,
replacing the few thoughts the creature itself
had. It felt itself lifting its hands from
the ground, lifting them and reaching towards
something - A glass box. The glass shattered
and those long, white fingers reached for
something within.
A mask. Just like the voice had said. A mask
to stop people from looking at its face…
Yes, yes, you’re doing so well. You’re
so close. Just a little further…
SCP-096 lifted the mask to its face, feeling
black liquid that burned its skin dripping
from the porcelain, and put it on. And in
that moment, everything changed.
The Shy Guy’s body began to seize up, rattling
as the mask unleashed a web of psychic tendrils
through its body, mapping out across every
inch like a new nervous system, taking control.
The Possessive Mask had never experienced
a host like this before - That incredible,
perfect mix of physical durability and a mind
so insubstantial that it was easy to sublimate.
Oh, this was going to be fun…
For the first time, the Shy Guy - now under
the full control of the Possessive Mask - stood
at full height on its hind legs, its spine
and shoulders clicking into place for its
new stance. The Mask cracked its neck, getting
used to the new dimensions of its physicality.
Its indestructible bones. Its long, grasping
limbs. Its skin, burning and fizzling with
the gooey black secretions, but growing back
just as quickly. The Foundation had every
reason to fear it now.
A group of security personnel had gathered
in the ragged hole where the chamber’s north
wall used to be. Some were wielding light
firearms; the guard at the front was carrying
an opaque black bag.
The Mask laughed with its new body and turned
to the crowd. The second they saw it on 096’s
body, their faces fell. For a moment, their
bodies went slack with terror. This situation
was unprecedented. What course of action could
they possibly take at a time like this?
It looked at the bag held by the leader of
the security force and projected a single
thought into his mind: You won’t be needing
that.
Before any of the guards even had a chance
to open fire, the Mask lunged forwards, using
the long, terrible arms of the Shy Guy to
tear through the guards. They were dead in
seconds, their bodies strewn about the hallway.
The mask’s porcelain was twisted into a
wide, sadistic grin. It could tell that it
was about to have some real fun around here
- and once it’d slaughtered everyone here,
it could finally stretch its legs out in the
open again. True freedom to spread misery,
fear, and pain everywhere it went.
There were just a few hundred members of Foundation
personnel it needed to turn into corpses,
first.
More containment breach alarms sounded around
the site as the Mask began its rampage, running
through the hallways and tearing apart any
unfortunate Foundation personnel it could
get 096’s hands on. Guards, researchers,
administrative staff, and even one extremely
unlucky janitor in Hallway C6. It was having
the time of its long and terrible life, and
much to its glee, it seemed that this new
host’s body was still holding up. It was
perfect symbiosis - A twisted, brilliant mind
and a body that could forever support it.
There would be no stopping it, a conclusion
that the hapless guards posted around the
site soon realized on their own terms. 096
was indestructible, but it was dumb as a brick
and had an easily exploitable weakness: Get
the bag on its head and you’re home free.
This new composite creature was a different
story. It could think tactically, avoiding
head-on confrontations in favor of sneak attacks,
and the monster had as much psychic combat
potential as physical. Guards roving the building
in teams, heavily armed, with anti-memetic
protective gear, still reported feeling immense
feelings of psychological dread over comms.
That was the greatest sign that The Mask would
come bursting through the wall moments later
and tear them to shreds.
The Site Director put out an urgent call for
all nearby Mobile Task Forces to intercept
and help them take care of the unfolding situation.
Thankfully, a detachment of MTF Eta-10, also
known as "See No Evil", was operating on a
case in close proximity. Given their specialization
in anomalies with a memetic visual property,
many on the team had dealt with 096 breaches
before. That at least gave them experience
in half of this situation.
And one operative among them, Sergeant Henrique
Ramirez, would be the one to bring this nightmare
to an end. But it would cost him his life
in the process.
The Mask was still using its new indestructible
body to wreak havoc on the containment site.
Once it had taken out the primary contingents
of guards, it was free to have its fun with
the rest: Stalking defenseless researchers
through the halls, making sure to induce maximum
terror before finally striking the killing
blow. Every single one of them died with a
head full of demonic whispers - it told them
of the Mask’s eternal dominion. Now, it
had found the perfect host, nothing on earth
would stop it. Humans would be mere ants under
its feet.
Eta-10 touched down and entered the building.
Ramirez was point man, leading the others
into the bowels of the blood-drenched containment
site. They’d been briefed on what they were
heading in for: 096 and 035 had reached symbiosis
and were displaying unprecedented anomalous
effects. Enter with extreme caution - They’re
beyond dangerous, even more so together than
alone.
Ideally, Ramirez would have wanted to go in
with a comprehensive plan, but lives were
on the line here. They needed to leap off
the cliff and build their wings on the way
down.
It was only when they finally encountered
the monster that they realized just how outmatched
they were. Despite their best efforts, the
combined speed, intelligence, and ferocity
of the Mask’s new form allowed it to make
short work of Eta-10. Only Ramirez was left,
heavily injured. Even if a miracle happened,
he knew he wasn’t getting out of here alive.
The Mask grabbed him with one of 096’s claws
and lifted him up. It would take its time
with this one. Make him suffer. Watch him
squirm. Destroy his mind.
Ramirez felt the Mask’s psychic tendrils
penetrate the membrane of his mind. Those
whispers, those terrible whispers, reciting
all his worst fears with terrible glee. His
gun was out of ammo. His knife was broken.
All he had left on him was a pocket mirror.
And that was his eureka moment. It was a long
shot, but it was also his only shot.
He reached out and grabbed the bottom of the
mask, pulling for dear life. His other hand
shot into his pocket and grabbed the mirror,
opening its lid with a deft flick of his thumb.
It was all too fast for the Mask to even register
what was going on.
Ramirez forced his eyes shut and lifted up
the mirror. The Mask saw its own reflection
in the glass, as the bottom of its face came
loose, revealing the reflection of the face
underneath.
The Mask squeezed, killing Ramirez, but it
was already too late. It had finally seen
the face of its host, and that would cost
it dearly.
The Mask felt a sudden and tremendous pushback
to its psychic forces - A blind despair and
then rage that choked out everything. SCP-096
began to sob and howl. Somehow, the Mask was
no longer in control.
Despite its psychic protests, 096 reached
up and tore the terrible mask from its face,
tossing it against the wall with such force
that it was embedded in the brickwork. Its
last thoughts, as other Mobile Task Force
operators descended on the area to bag 096
and return it to its containment chamber,
were: What the hell just happened?
And the next thought that crossed the mind
of the Site Director was, “Request site
transfer for 035 as soon as possible. Don’t
want a repeat of this incident any time soon…”
Imagine knowing that there’s a monster,
right under your nose. Imagine knowing that
this monster is capable of killing any human
being on earth, and all because they simply
saw a photograph of its face. When this monster
is on the warpath, literally nothing can stop
it. No weapon that human beings have invented
is capable of even slowing it down.
Imagine knowing, in the age of mass media,
of clicks and shares, of 24 hour news, smart
phones, and limitless social media connecting
billions across the globe, that one stray
picture of this monster leaked in the wrong
place could cause the end of the world as
we know it. And this fateful, terrifying day
could come at any time.
Congratulations, you now know how it feels
to be Dr. Dan, the hot-headed lead SCP Foundation
researcher on the SCP-096 case. The anomaly
itself requires no real introduction - the
infamous, mass-murdering Shy Guy has haunted
the nightmares of Foundation experts for years.
But nobody is more haunted by this thing than
Dr. Dan himself.
For over a decade now, he has firmly believed
that there’s one solution to the 096 problem:
Termination, with extreme prejudice. In his
eyes, to think that 096 is ever truly contained
is an illusion. They could never be sure of
how many pictures of it are out there, floating
around just waiting to be seen, like a time
bomb waiting to go off. The resources spent
containing it and cleaning up after its rampages,
he would often argue, would be better spent
instead figuring out how to finally kill it.
But seeing as we’re talking about the SCP
Foundation here, not the Global Occult Coalition,
the O5 Council didn’t see it quite the same
way. They constantly overturned Dr. Dan’s
termination requests, leaving the paranoid
researcher more furious with each rejection.
He tried to warn them, again and again and
again.
“Don’t you see? It’s like a stick of
dynamite, and the fuse is already lit. If
you don’t let me put it out before it’s
too late, there won’t even be anyone left
to pick up the pieces!”
But his pleas fell on deaf ears. Until, of
course, Incident 096-1-a, a dark and bloody
day still looked back on with shame and horror
by even the most hardened members of Foundation
staff.
It was the day that SCP-096 gave everyone
a taste of the mass carnage it was truly capable
of.
Dr. Dan wasn’t even there when containment
was first breached. He was off on an expedition
in the snowy mountains where 096 was first
found, trying to discover clues to its true
origin. Dr. Dan’s second in command, Dr.
Oleksei, was also lucky enough to be outside
of the containment area when the Shy Guy escaped.
According to interviews he gave at debriefing
tribunals, he was in the break room, treating
himself to a warm cup of joe.
All the other personnel assigned to 096’s
containment and research were near its containment
chamber, a giant cube made of reinforced metal,
observing a live feed of data being collected
from the cube’s interior. As usual, sensors
indicated that 096 was pacing within. For
obvious reasons, the Foundation doesn’t
maintain any kind of live visual surveillance
on 096. It wouldn’t be worth the risk.
But what seemed like an otherwise quiet day
suddenly took a turn for the insane. The monitors
began displaying terrifying data, indicating
an imminent containment breach, as the wails
of the creature within the cube echoed out
through its metal walls.
Some tried to run. Others did all they could
to engage emergency procedures, while guards
armed with heavy weaponry rushed into the
room. They all knew in their hearts that it
wouldn’t save them, but what else could
they do?
A huge dent bulged out from the side of the
cube, then another, before the metal was torn
open like tissue paper as the furious hands
of the Shy Guy began clawing their way through
it. Secondary layers of protection were deployed,
but they didn’t help, 096 just kept ripping
through all the barriers. As everyone in attendance
knew: Once it was in its rage state, nothing
could stop it. Literally nothing.`
The guards attempted to fire on the anomaly,
but their bullets did no good. As the creature
burst free, most of the people in the room
had at least momentary visual contact with
its face. In response, Code Lima was declared,
and the entire chamber was flooded with a
fast-acting nerve gas, killing everyone.
Everyone except for 096 itself of course.
Within two minutes, 096 had broken free of
the entire containment site, and began running
through the desert at breakneck speeds towards
its distant target. The Foundation needed
to act fast and find a way to stop it before
it hit a population center where the death
toll would skyrocket.
Team Echo Romeo were dispatched to pursue
the creature in a heavily-armed attack helicopter
while MTF Tau-1, a task force specializing
in SCP-096 containment and recovery, forged
ahead to identify the anomaly’s target,
designated 096-1, and to move any other civilians
out of harm’s way. Dr. Dan was alerted of
the disastrous situation and offered guidance
to both teams from afar.
Echo Romeo’s chopper pursued 096, barely
able to keep up. Dr. Dan recommended attempting
to at least slow the creature down with heavy
arms fire, even though he knew actually stopping
it would be impossible. A member of the team
used a modified XM500 anti-materiel rifle
to fire several rounds at the creature, but
even the shot that passed directly through
its head appeared to have no effect on it.
But at least they had a lock on its direction
now. 096 always travels in a straight line,
directly towards its target, smashing through
any obstacles in its way. This means its intended
direction is relatively easy to track, and
people in the path of its trajectory are even
easier to save - but it’s a high-pressure
job reserved for MTF Tau-1.
Tau-1 passed over Echo Romeo and 096 in a
series of eight v-22 Ospreys, hoping beyond
hope that they could outrun the creature;
since there were several different towns in
its direct path.
But, thanks once again to the one and only
Dr. Dan, Echo Romeo and Tau-1 had a secret
weapon that neither team had ever possessed
before: SCRAMBLE. SCRAMBLE was an advanced
computer program, created by Dr. Dan with
the help of Dr. Oleksei, which was coded into
microprocessors for modification into camera
feeds and viewing goggles. The program had
been fed intricate data concerning every single
detail of 096’s face, and as the name suggests,
when encountering that visual data in real
life it scrambles it beyond recognition.
In theory, it would make it far safer for
operatives to be around SCP-096 without activating
its rage state.
In theory.
It wasn’t long before disaster struck. 096
had made its way onto I-40, and had begun
attacking vehicles it encountered, killing
the people inside. By this point, it had already
outrun the Echo Romeo chopper, rendering them
essentially useless. Tau-1 just had to forge
ahead along 096’s trajectory, and try to
get as many people out of the danger zone
as possible until 096-1 was located and destroyed
by the anomaly.
Years of training for an awful day like this
had paid off, as the first three towns along
096’s path were successfully evacuated.
The Shy Guy just ran right through all of
them, and no lives were lost. The same, however,
could not be said for town number four.
As was standard procedure, Tau-1 had everyone
in town gathered up and blindfolded. The entire
team in attendance had modified night vision
goggles with SCRAMBLE microprocessors, so
in theory, they were better off than most
from 096 if things went south.
The Tau-1 members tried in vain to keep everybody
in line. They were threatening to shoot anyone
who dared to remove their blindfold when 096
finally appeared. It tripped during its approach,
rolling and shattering through several houses.
Chaos erupted. Some people instinctively removed
their blindfolds to see what was going on,
and panicked members of Tau-1 began firing
into the crowd.
The screams of the civilians and the bursts
of gunfire were all drowned out by the horrific
wailing of 096 itself as it tore through everyone
and everything to kill the unfortunate souls
who had seen its face. And given how many
had removed their blindfolds during the initial
pandemonium, SCP-096 had a huge number of
the townspeople on its list.
096 located and grabbed the original 096-1,
the person that’d first glimpsed its face
and caused all this, but in the grand scheme
of things, he was just one more body on the
pile that day. Though of course, we mean this
in a purely metaphorical sense - 096 never
leaves entire bodies.
The Foundation operatives in attendance were
able to figure out what had caused all this
madness and death. 096-1 had been an amateur
mountaineer, and spent his vacations hiking
around any mountain ranges he could gain access
to - including the mountain range that 096
had been inhabiting prior to its initial capture
and containment. But he hadn’t actually
seen 096 on that fateful trip, which he had
taken over a decade ago.
But in a photograph taken that day of himself,
standing on a picturesque mountainside, 096
made a cameo. It took up all of four pixels,
a tiny off-white dot against the snow on the
back-right side of the photograph. This photograph,
with all the deadly potency of an atom bomb,
had been sitting there for years. Waiting.
When the mountaineer was looking through old
photos that morning and his eyes passed over
those few blurry pixels, he didn’t have
any idea that he had just laid his eyes on
one of the most dangerous anomalies the world
has ever seen.
But you don’t have to know. Only 096 does.
As Tau-1, led by their commander, Major Jack
Wilford, tried to retake control of the situation,
things got even worse. It turned out, Dr.
Dan’s SCRAMBLE technology - the one thing
that was supposed to have given them an edge
in this situation - didn’t actually work.
As soon as goggle wearing members of the team
laid eyes on 096, it entered its rage state
and started massacring them.
It tore many of the Mobile Task Force members
to shreds, including a number of the operatives
required for piloting the eight Ospreys. It
was a disaster of truly epic proportions,
and the catastrophic failure of Dr. Dan’s
SCRAMBLE technology was a key factor.
The root of the technology’s failure was
easy enough to figure out. Dr. Dan’s SCRAMBLE
microprocessors worked fast, but not fast
enough. Fractions-of-a-second glimpses of
096’s face managed to get through, and that
was more than enough to set 096 off.
Echo Romeo and MTF Epsilon arrived shortly
afterwards to clean up the mess. It’d been
a disaster of such magnitude that even a CNN
reporter arrived on the scene and started
filming before being promptly shut down by
Epsilon. It was a member of Echo Romeo that
finally slipped the bag over a docile 096’s
head, preparing it for containment once again,
the creature now content that it had eliminated
all of the unfortunate souls who had seen
its face.
He’d found 096 sitting next to a minivan
that had its roof ripped off, the young family
inside being the last to have seen its face.
Things were so awful in the aftermath of the
containment breach that the O5 Council changed
their tune, finally granting Dr. Dan permission
to terminate 096, by any means necessary.
It’s terrifying to think that all this can
unfold because of a couple of poorly-timed
accidents. But it’s probably even more terrifying
to consider that it wasn’t an accident at
all. It had seemed awfully convenient that
both Dr. Dan and Dr. Oleksei were far from
danger when all hell broke loose. It was also
convenient that, despite the failure of his
technology being a major reason why the breach
was as deadly as it was, Dr. Dan had still
come out of the situation with everything
he wanted.
The Foundation also found this strange, and
the more they looked into it, the more they
found details that didn’t add up. Alibis
began to fall apart. Coincidences didn’t
seem so coincidental, and eventually a weak
link in the chain was identified - Dr. Oleksei.
Under pressure from the Foundation, Oleksei
spilled everything. Dr. Dan had essentially
orchestrated the entire containment breach,
and on top of that, he did everything he could
to make it as deadly as possible. All with
the purpose of getting the O5 Council to see
things his way, and finally give him the permission
he needed to devote all of the SCP-096 resources
to its termination.
But it came at a terrible price to Dr. Dan
personally. For his crimes against the Foundation
and humanity, he was permitted to try and
figure out a way to terminate 096 once and
for all, but as payment for his crimes, he
himself would also be terminated as soon as
his task was complete.
Were the lives of all of those innocent people,
and Dr. Dan’s himself, worth the price of
finally being authorized to terminate SCP-096?
When asked why he did all this, Dr. Dan simply
said…
“It worked. There was only a matter of time
until that happened in a major population
center, and its face spread over the world
news. I can kill 096, but I’ve killed myself
in the process.”
While we don’t agree with his methods, there’s
something almost admirable about a person
so single mindedly devoted to their cause.
As you walk down the halls of the SCP Foundation
Site-19, peeking in the various windows at
the anomalies contained there, you might catch
a glimpse of a dark figure bent over a table,
tinkering away like an artisan in his workshop.
A vintage black apothecary bag sits next to
him, open, and if you stop and watch for a
while, you’ll see him pull all manner of
tools out of it. Impossibly large tools, things
that shouldn’t fit in such a small bag:
a bone saw, an IV stand, jars of fluorescent
liquids and needles the length of your forearm.
You shouldn’t be surprised, this is a place
for impossible things, after all. Still, it’s
a curious sight, the shadowy man working so
diligently, so quietly, focused singularly
on his craft. Whatever that may be.
Only one thing could distract him from his
efforts: you. He feels your gaze on him, and
he looks up, dark eyes glittering from behind
a beaked ceramic mask. He reminds you of an
illustration you once saw in a book about
the Black Death, the gear the plague doctors
wore while treating patients on their deathbeds.
“Hello!” He greets you in a friendly,
heavily accented voice. His eyes crinkle beneath
the mask, and if you could see his mouth you
know he’d be smiling. “How are you today,
dear fellow? Are you feeling quite well?”
He takes a step toward the window, stretching
out one gloved hand, and you suddenly realize
that you can’t see where the mask ends and
his skin begins…it’s not a mask, but a
part of his face. This is no ordinary man.
“Do you require help? I can examine you…”
He offers, palm pressed flat against the glass.
A chill runs up your spine, and you realize
that you should definitely not take him up
on his offer. No matter how friendly he seems,
how good his intentions may be, you wouldn’t
want to let the Plague Doctor treat you.
He sat in his containment cell, fidgeting
with his favorite scalpel. He dragged it over
the surface of his work table, back and forth,
listening to the sound it made. They had tried
to confiscate his table, his tools, but the
guards had quickly learned that he had more
of them in his bag. They tried to take his
bag from him, but, well, that didn’t go
over too well for anyone involved. So, he
was allowed to keep it, to fashion himself
a makeshift laboratory in his lonely little
cell. There was a time when they had given
him test subjects, fresh corpses from the
morgue for him to dissect and research. There
was a time when the doctors here would come
to speak to him, talking of cryptobiology
and the pestilence he had dedicated himself
to fighting.
Those days were long gone. He had hidden away
pieces of the corpses, tissue samples in jars
of formaldehyde he could pull out when the
monotony became too much, but the days of
fresh materials, of enlightened discourse
with other men and women of science, were
over. How he missed those days, the chance
to work with others as he once had.
What had he done wrong? All he did was treat
the sick. Sure, they didn’t always understand
their illness, didn’t want to receive their
medicine, but that wasn’t a choice for the
patient to make. That should have been up
to the physician. Perhaps they didn’t trust
his expertise, didn’t see how his work served
the greater good. Like those who watched Jonas
Salk invent the polio vaccine, or Louis Pasteur
rid milk of bacteria, they were confused by
the advanced scientific practices and feared
that which they did not understand.
He could forgive them for their ignorance,
he was magnanimous that way. If only they
would let him out of this infernal room, he
could prove his work’s worth to them. He
could cure them all, begin a new era of wellness
and peace worldwide. He didn’t exactly sleep,
but when he rested on his little cot in the
corner of the room, he dreamed of that future.
Of a world healed by his touch. A knock at
the door stirred him from his reverie. Someone
was at the door of his containment cell. He
glanced at the little window, and saw a guard
there with a tray of food. He greeted the
man with an enthusiastic wave. Sustenance!
He didn’t require the food for survival,
of course, but it helped his mind work more
efficiently. It reminded him of a time before
these fluorescent lights and these same four
walls, of crusty bread with fresh butter by
the banks of the Seine.
A little slot opened in the door, and the
tray was shoved through. There was bread,
just as he’d hoped. A small dish of butter,
a pot of jam, and a cup of tea, still steaming.
He picked up the cup first, taking a deep
breath. Ah, an herbal blend, with fresh lavender.
Lovely. He couldn’t see the guard through
the window anymore, but he called out to him
just the same, “Thank you for the libations!”
He still had his manners after all, even in
confinement. He wished he could have gotten
a better look at the man, seen the pallor
of his complexion, a tremor in his hand. He
thought he had spotted sweat, beading on his
forehead. Could he be ill? The case required
further examination, to be certain. He sighed,
clutching the cup of tea tighter in frustration.
Why wouldn’t they just let him work? Why
must they scream at the sight of his efforts,
flee from his instruments? It didn’t seem
fair.
Still, the pursuit of science rarely was a
glamorous one. He had learned as much over
the centuries. One day, though, history would
look back on him kindly. Of this, he could
be certain.
He was just settling in and beginning to spread
butter across the admittedly stale bread,
when a horrible sound shook him to attention.
He had heard the noise before, though he had
never seen its source. It was an ear splitting
scream, a wail of pure agony like the sound
of a wounded wild animal. He had heard many,
many screams during his life, from patients
and those who stood in the way of his work,
but until he had been brought into the custody
of the Foundation, he had never heard a scream
quite like this one. It was pure rage, devastation,
and suffering mixed together, wet with tears
and loud enough to rip through human vocal
cords.
Whatever was crying out, it was no mere man.
More screams answered it, and these were very
much human. These sounds were more familiar
to him, shrieks of pain, of fear, of desperate
(but futile) attempts to escape. Then, the
meaty thud of bodies falling to the floor,
of torn off limbs hitting walls and windows.
A loud crash. And the sound of something large
moving quite quickly through the halls.
Scientific curiosity got the better of the
Doctor, and he found himself moving back to
his little window, face pressed to the glass
so hard his beak nearly cracked it. He couldn’t
see much of anything, just guards running
down the hall, weapons drawn. He saw one of
them fire, heard the gunshot ring out. What
was he firing at?
Then, he saw it: a pale blur darting past
the door. Whatever it was, it didn’t so
much as flinch when the bullet ricocheted
off its skin. A long, thin arm crashed against
the door, knocking the Doctor backwards into
his work table. He steadied himself and climbed
back to his feet, taking in the damage done
to the door. It was crumpled in on itself,
nearly ripped off the hinges, and whatever
had ploughed into it was already gone. From
the sounds of chaos in the distance, it had
disappeared around the corner, with the guards
following it.
He inspected the ruins of the door to his
containment cell. It was useless now, hanging
loose and open. Well, that was an invitation
he was hardly about to decline. He grabbed
his trusty bag, tossed his scalpel back inside,
and set off to see what all the commotion
was. It was easy enough to follow the trail
of blood, stark and vivid red against the
white tile floor, and the sound of gunfire,
human screams, and that loud, long, painful
wail he had heard before.
He walked at a leisurely pace, taking his
time, until the sound suddenly stopped. He
rounded the corner, and found a mound of bodies,
guards and scientists, beaten and bloodied
almost beyond recognition. It was quiet here,
save for one sound: the sound of weeping.
There, in the corner, huddled over with its
face to the wall, was a pale, thin figure,
its shoulders heaving with the force of its
sobs. This poor soul was clearly in great
distress. It was a peculiar sight, hairless
and white, distended arms wrapped around itself
as it cried.
“Excuse me!” The Doctor called out to
the pitiful creature. “Are you alright?
Do you need assistance?”
It didn’t answer, it just continued to cry.
Had something so despondent been responsible
for this destruction? The dozens of corpses,
the smashed-in walls, the crumbled doors and
shattered windows. It seemed impossible. Sure,
it was large, and looked strong, but he had
never seen a monster cry before. This couldn’t
be a dangerous creature, not when it was so
sad. He would help it. But first, he would
attend to some of these bodies. He sat his
bag on the ground, and pulled out several
vials of liquid, a set of syringes, and a
variety of other surgical tools he might need.
Now, after such a long hiatus, he could resume
his work in a meaningful way.
He couldn’t be certain how long he worked,
reviving these poor souls and reconstructing
their bodies, as the pale creature wept in
the corner. The sobbing faded into the background
for a while, becoming a kind of white noise
as he removed a liver here, placed it in a
chest cavity there, poked and prodded, injected
and extracted, testing out new methods alongside
tried and true cures. One by one, the milky
eyes fluttered open, rigor mortis-stiff joints
creaked into motion, sallow faces looking
at his with the vacant gratitude he saw in
so many patients over the years.
He didn’t need them to thank him with their
words, the work was its own reward. He kept
expecting more guards to arrive, to attempt
to contain the situation, but none came even
as the alarm blared overhead.
As for the morose creature, it didn’t seem
to notice his presence at all, not even when
he had brought all of the intact corpses back
to life. The patients shuffled about the room
aimlessly, waiting for orders of some kind.
The doctor tapped one on the shoulder, and
handed the reborn man a vial of thick black
medicine.
“Give this to the poor fellow in the corner,
please.” It wasn’t much, but it should
calm him, provide some relief from his suffering.
The corpse nodded, mouth hanging loose and
open, an eyeball dangling, unseeing, from
the socket. He shuffled over to the strange
creature, and held out the vial to it. It
turned, lifting its head, and as it locked
eyes with the cured patient, something shifted
in its face. Its mouth opened wide, impossibly
wide, and it shrieked, that same terrible
sound as before.
Tears streamed from its colorless eyes, its
arms shaking with unbridled rage, as its jaws
locked around the patient’s head. Like a
boa constrictor, in one fluid motion it swallowed
the revived man whole, while the Doctor watched
in shock.
He had been wrong, this was not an innocent
caught in the wrong place at the wrong time.
This creature, whatever it was, was deeply
sick. He had never seen such an advanced,
aggressive case of the Pestilence. He’d
heard rumors, of course, but never encountered
it firsthand. As a Doctor, he had sworn to
do no harm, but in a drastic situation, drastic
measures have to be taken. It was well known,
by himself and the doctors at this Foundation,
that he could cause any and all biological
functions in an organism to cease with a single
touch. And so, he approached the creature,
arm outstretched, ready to administer that
necessary touch to protect the rest of his
patients.
As he approached, the creature turned to him,
its eyes wide and blank, an endless stream
of tears pouring from them, spilling onto
the floor. It shrieked again, mouth stretching
wide enough to engulf his entire head, and
ran toward him at a breakneck speed.
“I’m so sorry, you’re not well…”
The Doctor said simply, as his hand pressed
to the creature’s chest. As soon as the
tough hide of the Doctor’s hand (which the
uninformed might mistake for gloves) made
contact with the unpigmented skin of the beast,
its eyes closed, its muscles went slack, and
it collapsed to the ground with a mighty thud.
The Doctor paced around the fallen creature,
taking in the sight. Then, something strange
caught his eye. The creature’s chest still
rose, and fell. Was it his imagination? He
checked its pulse, and though it was slow
and faint, it was very much present. The creature
was still alive. It had merely been rendered
unconscious by his touch, rather than completely
deceased.
“Curious…very curious indeed,” he muttered.
Perhaps there were comorbidities present,
other infections aside from the Pestilence
which rendered the creature unnaturally strong,
resilient to the usual courses of treatment.
What would cause these abilities, this intense
aggression? It seemed to be brought on whenever
someone looked at the entity’s face.
If only he’d studied psychology more, the
science of the mind and its inner workings.
Since he had no experience with therapy, nor
was he certain this creature could communicate
using language at all, there was only one
way to find out more about how this creature’s
brain worked: he would have to take it apart
and see for himself.
It was slow work, getting the massive creature
back to the Doctor’s containment cell. He
required the help of his cured patients, who
grasped it by its massive limbs and dragged
the limp body through the halls. Once back
in a familiar environment, his work table
ready and waiting, the Doctor instructed his
assistants to place the new patient on the
table. It was a bit small, unable to accommodate
the creature’s distended limbs, but if he
attempted to use an official Foundation laboratory,
he risked discovery and subsequent interruption.
So, it would have to suffice.
First, he set up an IV stand, filled with
a vivid green liquid. It was easy to find
a vein, the creature’s skin was nearly translucent.
Now that he could be certain the creature
would not wake during surgery, he could make
the first incision.
“Scalpel.” He held out a hand, and his
favorite surgical blade was placed in it by
one of the helpful patients. “Thank you.”
He slid the scalpel along the hairline of
the creature, or where the hairline would
be if it weren’t completely bald. Once the
scalp was removed, he set it aside for later,
when it could be reattached. “Bone saw,
please.” He held out his hand again, and
again his assistant gave him the proper tool.
This, however, was when things got strange.
The Doctor had always been a deft hand at
cutting - he’d once even received tutelage
from the great Robert Liston - but no matter
how hard he tried to saw, it never left a
scratch on the creature’s skeleton. Naturally,
this was somewhat frustrating - He wanted
to study the creature’s brain tissue, to
get a sense for what was going on up there,
neuroligically. And he couldn’t do that
if it was impossible to saw off the creature’s
cranial cap. He blunted two of his favorite
saws while trying!
Thankfully, there was still a solution to
accessing the beast’s grey matter: A little
trick he’d learned while studying the funerary
practices of the ancient Egyptians. He produced
a long, curved hook from his bag and inserted
it up the creature’s nasal passage. With
some fine manoeuvring, he eventually managed
to remove the brain. It was such a terrible
shame that he needed to do it piece by piece
via the nasal passage, but one makes do. All
that was left was to sew the skin of the creature’s
head back into place.
He was mid-stitch when a voice interrupted
his careful work, nearly making him drop the
needle.
“Hey! What are you doing?”
He looked up to find a guard, aiming a gun
at his face.
“Excuse me, I am in surgery at the moment.
Please do not interrupt!” He admonished
the guard, but the man did not listen or lower
his weapon.
In fact, he shouted something into a radio,
code words the Doctor didn’t recognize.
Then, he fired a bullet into the skull of
the patient standing at his side.
“How dare you!” the Doctor cried, readying
himself to confront the guard. But it was
too late, dozens of other guards were swarming
the room and neutralizing his assistants,
some in hazmat suits grabbed his arms and
pulled him away from the creature on the operating
table, no matter how hard he fought or how
loudly he protested.
Then, something incredible happened. Something
wonderful.
The creature opened its eyes, and sat up.
It looked directly at the guard closest to
it, and the two saw one another’s faces.
The guard tensed, preparing for the worst…but
nothing came. The creature simply stared,
placid and quiet. No screaming, no tearing
at flesh, no mouth opening wider and wider
to swallow the man whole.
“I did it!” The Doctor shouted, overcome
with elation. “I’ve cured you! Now begins
the rest of your happy life!”
He watched as the guards led the shockingly
calm creature away, back to its containment
cell. The Doctor’s door was repaired, and
he was returned to his state of captivity.
But he never forgot the patient he helped
that day, and how marvelous it felt to do
such a good deed.
Meanwhile, SCP-096’s brain regrew within
the hour, and caused another massive containment
breach, murdering a variety of researchers
and guards. But the staff agreed not to tell
SCP-049 about any of this. Better to just
let him have this one, he really seemed like
he needed a win.
The SCP Foundation’s hallowed halls have
been the site of many great and puzzling mysteries.
Among them being, who was the true creator
of SCP-173, the neck-snapping Sculpture? What
are the secrets that Dr. Alto Clef is keeping
about his past? Who are the true seven children
of the Scarlet King? Who was SCP-106, the
Old Man, before he got all nasty? And of course,
what is the true nature and origin of SCP-096
- The violent, terrifying, and incredibly
withdrawn Shy Guy?
It’s a question so great that we knew even
our experts here at SCP Explained couldn’t
take on the mission alone. That’s why we
pooled the resources of you, the loyal viewers
of SCP Explained, to find the answer. We made
a community post asking for your personal
theories on how the Shy Guy came to be, and
you didn’t disappoint, sending in a cavalcade
of curious conjecture that we just can’t
wait to explore.
So let’s hop right in and see what all of
you had to say!
Here is PuffyShade’s theory:
“He was a lost British D-class named Martin
McGregor. On a risky experiment in Columbia
regarding SCP-1290, a D-class prisoner was
teleported to an unknown mountainous location
after a malfunction in the device. He stayed
there for 37 hours before dying of his bullet
wounds from being shot by foreign soldiers.
Wherever the D-class was teleported to was
a foreign country not welcome to outsiders.
As we all know, there have been some SCPs
that have escaped the grasp of the foundation.
The foundation has located them, but never
been able to see or capture them.
Continuing with the story, it is speculated
that one of these entities that is still undiscovered
had the power of necromancy. They brought
the D-class back to the mortal world, but
in an immortal form. To terrorize humanity
forever. The entity brings humans back to
life as supernatural beings, their powers
being determined by their former personality.
The resurrected D-class was always shy, self
conscious of his unattractive face.
As you can probably guess, this resulted in
the birth of our good old friend,
Shy Guy.”
Certainly a fascinating direction to go, with
a basis in recorded anomalous activity. And
much like a few other anomalies originating
from D-Class personnel, such as SCP-2419,
the Laughing Men, and SCP-4973, the Dead Men
Walking, it would feel oddly satisfying to
see another one of the Foundation’s greatest
mistakes become one of the gravest threats.
Here is DiamondStar Lemon’s theory:
“The Shy Guy was Andrew Irvine, one of 2
mountaineers that went missing who were part
of the British expedition that was sent to
reach the top of Mount Everest in 1924.
While Andrew and his friend George Mallory
were heading for camp 5 , they encountered
SCP-1529 at different intervals. Since Mallory's
body was eventually found in 1999 this tells
us that Irvine also encountered 1529. Irvine
constantly rejected 1529's offers and eventually
developed a defense mechanism where he gets
aggressive and attacks SCP-1529, in return
1529 prolonged his life by years to make him
suffer every single minute. His skin turned
white due to constant exposure to the sun
and he took off all of his clothes due to
hypothermia.
This is confirmed because Mallory's body was
just as white as Irvine and a letter he sent
to his family says that Andrew became very
shy and barely speaks and he eventually disappears.
Mallory then encounters 1529 and punches him
in the face and then Mallory falls unconscious
leading to his death. Meanwhile Irvine loses
his sanity and has his body disfigured and
his hands developed claws for better climbing.”
This is another popular theory which has its
roots in pre-existing anomalous knowledge.
The horrific tortures by SCP-1529, the Mountain
King, against Andrew Irvine is believed by
many to be the root of the Shy Guy’s creation.
Of course, we can’t know for sure, but some
compelling evidence undeniably points in this
intriguing direction.
Here is #1 Try Hard’s Theory:
“I think he was one of the subjects in the
Russian Sleep Experiment that escaped and
ran into the Siberian mountains, became aware
of the monstrosity he had become, and became
violently self conscious.”
This is a strange and creative theory, wrapping
096 in with the lore of the legendary Russian
Sleep Experiment. Russia does have its fair
share of snowy mountain ranges, and the experiment
did turn its unfortunate subjects into horrifying
monsters. But the nature of these monsters
did differ significantly from the Shy Guy
- showing higher intelligence, but far less
durability against physical trauma.
Here is Avery Spencer’s theory:
“I have wondered if perhaps he was part
of an almost Dyatlov Pass incident and was
the sole survivor. Being in such a position
he was forced to eat his comrades. He then
took on almost wendigo aspects, but instead
of the blood thirsty feelings most got he
became so ashamed of what he did he can no
longer tolerate someone looking at him.”
This is another incredibly interesting theory
that has its basis in both Russian legend
and real life history. There have been a number
of events in the snowy mountains of Russia,
much like the Dyatlov Pass Incident, which
have left high-altitude tragedies in their
wake. One of these, traumatizing its victim
to the point of turning them into an anomalous
creature like SCP-096 definitely doesn’t
seem out of the question.
Here is Kyreikal’s theory:
“Shy Guy has no face. His face does not
exist. Not in the sense that its just smooth
skin, the face is actually nothing.
He is a body and mind directly attached to
a pattern screamer. Humans expect humanoid
shaped creatures to have a face. Thus when
someone sees his "face" the screamer takes
over and destroys that person so it can stop
existing. His body has changed over the years
to facilitate eliminating people who see the
"face" more effectively. This is why he wants
to dissappear in the desire camera, finish
being nothing so people stop filling in his
face.
A way it could have happened is an incomplete
encounter with 3930. The one who became the
shy guy leaned in and just his face ceased
to exist. Though he probably would have already
needed some anomalous traits to survive that.”
This is another extremely original and interesting
theory based in pre-existing anomalies. Of
course, there’s no real way to prove that
SCP-096’s face isn’t a pattern screamer,
given that to look upon it is to court death,
so we may just need to take your word on this
one…
Here is Lacintag’s theory:
“Perhaps 096 is an alien from a planet or
dimension that's completely dark, where being
seen is a death sentence because of the local
anomalous fauna. He somehow wound up in our
universe. Perhaps 096 is cursed that whoever
sees him will eventually transform into something
much worse, or become a portal into a dark
dimension. And he does us all a favor by eliminating
these people before that can happen.”
Another two extremely interesting theories,
both of which could potentially hold water.
They seem consistent with the fact that SCP-096
takes no pleasure in the killing of its victims,
it only seems to be doing it out of the sense
that it feels compelled into action.
Here is Chill Me’s theory:
“He could be the physical embodiment of
the feeling of body dysmorphia.”
Another very valid theory, given SCP-096’s
general temperament and caustic reactions
to being perceived in any way.
Here is Renan Roman’s theory:
“What would happen if Dr Bright looked at
scp 096's face? I mean, his host would certainly
be killed, but what would happen as soon as
Dr Bright picks another host? Would scp 096
instantaneously charge at the new host and
kill it as well?”
An interesting theory, and one that we’ve
explored ourselves on videos concerning Dr.
Bright before. It’s another good reason
that this particular scenario should be placed
on the “Dr. Bright is Not Allowed” list.
Though even though Dr. Bright does occasionally
beg for death, this is one horrifying recursive
fate that even Jack himself probably wouldn’t
enjoy.
Here is Hon Guy’s theory:
“From what I heard there are two theories,
one was the he was a mountaineer that survived
an encounter with the king of the mountain
and had to adapt to the mountain to survive
both from him and the mountain itself or he’s
actually one of the children of the Scarlet
King.”
While we’ve covered the Mountain King theory,
this Scarlet King theory is all new. Could
SCP-096 be a child of the terrifying Scarlet
King? He’s certainly destructive, but perhaps
he lacks the true knowing malice - the sadism
- that’d make that big, red, armored lunatic
proud. He certainly doesn’t have the abject
hatred of a 682.
Here is Clawed Cat’s theory:
“I wouldnt be surprised if he was a species
and came to be that way as it is perfectly
hidden. They blend in with the snow, and if
anyone saw its face to know it was there,
they couldn’t document it for obvious reasons.”
This is an interesting and terrifying concept.
A whole species of Shy Guys. This is another
good reason to ardently fight against climate
change - If all the snow melts, there’ll
be nowhere for them to hide anymore…
Here is Dan Wolf’s theory:
“The idea of "if a tree falls and no one
is around to hear it..." is his origin. He
is the physical manifestation of the energy
of all the things unseen, the sound of a falling
tree, the transparent skin of fish in the
abyssal zone, development on Halflife 3. All
these things exist but they do so UNSEEN.
SHY is physical manifestation of that metaphysical
energy, he didn't exist until he was seen
thus he came to be. Existing is painful to
him so he kills anyone who sees his face,
the thing we as humans use to identify one
another, in a hope to be unrecognized and
unknown to eventually no longer exists.”
This is a fascinating theory. Our one question
is how he could ever be seen if, by definition,
he is an avatar of the unseen? What would
cause these lapses in non-existence? It raises
an interesting metaphysical quandary in and
of itself…
Here is Jonathan Collier’s theory:
“The Shy Guy is a creation of the Plague
Doctor, who engineered him in the French Alps.
He began as a human, but the doctor's process
mutated him into his current form. He designed
him to destroy the pestilence, but he was
infected by it somewhere in the process. This
means that whenever someone sees his face,
they catch the pestilence.
His programming can't allow this, so he is
forced to destroy whoever sees him. The doctor's
programming was incomplete when he was corrupted,
so he only hunts those that he has infected
with the pestilence, not all that the Plague
Doctor deems infected. His indestructible
form is a combination of the Plague Doctor's
tinkering and treatments as well as the doctor
potentially incorporating DNA from other anomalous
creatures, such as 682, which did visit France
in Lord Blackwood's tales.
The doctor likely kept the DNA in reserve
for his ultimate device to destroy the pestilence,
however it failed and led to him releasing
the Shy Guy to roam the mountains, traveling
eventually from the Alps to the Himalayas
where he was discovered. The creature cries
as it kills it's victims because of it's human
beginnings, and it's apparent anxiety is likely
the lingering emotion it felt before it was
transformed, leading to it being repeated
for the rest of it's existence.”
We love the Plague Doctor here at SCP Explained,
so we’re always happy to consider fun potential
crossovers featuring him with some of our
other favorite anomalies. The one thing working
against this theory is that 096 is an uncharacteristically
effective creation for the Plague Doctor’s
standards, most of which are janky, disfigured
zombies. Sorry, 049.
Here is Devon Linder’s theory:
“I always felt like 096 was possessed by
an evil spirit that lives in the frost, essentially
the original native story of a wendigo. It
just all makes sense, deformities and strength,
lives in the cold, hunts and kills people.
I don’t know if there’s anything about
looking at a wendigo in the original stories
though.”
The Algonquin myth of the Wendigo certainly
does have some similarities to SCP-096, however,
it has a little more in common with another
anomaly - SCP-323, the Wendigo Skull, which
forces its wearers into spontaneous acts of
violence and cannibalism. Though if ever 096
found itself wearing the Wendigo Skull, we’d
all be in terrible trouble…
Here is EpicKitty 101’s theory:
“Not really a theory, it's just what I want
it to be. I believe that 096’s actions are
derived from trauma. It could very well be
a species and might be a different version,
like albino so whenever someone looks at its
face it feels as though that person was so
inconvenienced by its looks it wants to kill
them because he thinks they hate him now.
He believes he isn't good enough for anyone's
standards.”
We can all relate to that feeling now and
then. And the hysteric crying and wailing
of SCP-096 undeniably suggests a level of
psychological trauma. One thing we know for
sure: It definitely inflicts trauma on the
rest of us.
Here is Lemon Demon Danganronpa’s theory:
“Hear me out: When Day Breaks was actually
a primitive event, and the Shy Guy was the
result. Without any people to go around for
the next several millennia, The Shy Guy grew
fond of the lack of company, ultimately turning
him into the person-or monster-he is today.”
This is a fascinating one, however, there
is some pre-existing evidence - such as the
tale Unexpected Light, which we’ve covered
in a video on this channel - that suggest
SCP-096 survived into the reign of SCP-001
When Day Breaks. Though sadly, according to
that tale, he didn’t survive beyond it.
Here is Andrew Colon’s theory:
“I have a theory that he was born with some
deformities and super strength and was mocked
for it. As he grew older the deformities grew
more noticeable. So maybe the years of trauma
and abuse or what not have caused him to self
isolate and attack violently against anyone
who sees him.”
This definitely reflects the internality that
many people believe SCP-096 has: A frightened,
insecure creature, spiting its own creation
and anyone unfortunate enough to look upon
it. Though we’ll never really know how exactly
it got there…
Here is Stripeysox 101’s theory:
“He could have been one of the SCP-1000
instances but born hairless and unable to
think, so was abandoned by its parents.”
Another good cross-anomaly connection, however,
096 is significantly more durable than any
member of SCP-1000, as well as having far
more freakish proportions, so it’s unlikely
to have any real relation to this advanced
species of apes.
Here is Blue Iblis’ theory:
“Well based on his height, his reaction
to his face being seen, and how quick he is...
SCP-096 is literally just an IRL Enderman.
They're both tall, they're both able to move
quickly, and become instantly pissed if you
look at their face/eyes. This probably means
096 is maaaybe from another dimension, but
its just a theory.”
We might dismiss a potential Minecraft influence
out of hand, were it not for the existence
of SCP-4335, also known as A Welt In The Crucible,
an evil Minecraft monster. However, this monster
was actually the one responsible for the Ender
Men in Minecraft due to a Foundation-inspired
patch, sadly invalidating this theory.
Here is James Bevan’s theory:
“My theory is that the Shy Guy is a demon
summoned by a cult that dwelled in the mountains.
They hoped to control him, but were unaware
that the entity reacts violently whenever
anyone sees its face and all met a grisly
death.”
SCP-096 is undeniably rather… Demonic, so
we couldn’t argue with this theory on that
front. It’s also very likely that any cult
who unwittingly summoned him, without the
knowledge of his primary anomalous effect,
would meet a truly gruesome death at his claws
and teeth, so you may be on to something here,
James.
Here is Harrison O’Leary’s theory:
“Well, when he left the mushroom kingdom,
he obviously lost his mask and clothes.”
The idea that the Shy Guy is literally, well,
a Shy Guy, is certainly an intriguing one
- though how 096’s long, gangly body could
fit into those tiny, compact outfits is an
open question. If only Researcher Mario and
Researcher Luigi would take some time off
of their extremely busy schedules to help
us out with this one…
Here is Roninski’s theory:
“He was a very handsome man who was experimented
on, and now goes into violent fits of rage
when people look at his now disfigured face.”
Hmm. Is it just us, or is the idea of a strangely
handsome SCP-096 somehow even more disturbing
than the one we already have? Just feels so
unnatural…
He’s waiting for you in the dark. He sits,
cross-legged, still as a placid lake and patient
as a praying monk six feet deep in meditation.
He’s been like this for so long. His body
oil-slicked with deadly black grease, skin
ancient and haggard, eyes black and flat with
the kind of calm you only find in crawling
insects and Great White Sharks. His lipless
mouth is stretched across his jawbone in an
ugly, black rictus. He may be an Old Man,
but trust us, he’s got plenty of new tricks
he’d love to show you.
He sat in the loneliest place in the world:
The deep, dark bowels of an SCP Foundation
containment site, surrounded by a complex
confluence of containment measures: Different
shapes, running liquids, bright lights, the
kind of steel so thick a nuclear weapon would
only leave it scuffed. All the things that
had a tendency to... Confuse him. Because
that’s all they ever did.
The Old Man laughed to himself, very quietly.
All the people out there are so scared of
him because of one immutable fact: He isn’t
trapped here, he’s just resting. By virtue
of his unique anomalous abilities - to pass
through solids at will and resist any form
of physical damage they can dole out - there
is no way to really contain him like all the
others. All the SCP Foundation could hope
to do was make leaving inconvenient enough
for him to make his little adventures on the
outside less appealing than just sitting around,
doing nothing.
After all, he had all the time in the world,
and when you always have a “Later”, there’s
a lot less pressure to do anything now.
But like all thinking creatures - And please,
be aware that SCP-106, the wretched, terrifying
Old Man, is very much a thinking creature
- he was subject to occasional boredom. And
when most people are bored, they might play
a video game, watch a few YouTube videos,
or rewatch It’s Always Sunny In Philadelphia
for the fifth time. But for the Old Man, killing
boredom involved... Well, killing people.
But not just killing people, of course. Truth
be told, for him, killing was really the least
entertaining part of the whole affair.
The screams? The begging? The desperate pleas?
Warm tears on shaking cheeks? Convulsions
of pain? Cold sweats? Fear so intense it gives
way to gibbering madness? That dull sheen
of dead hope in their eyes when they then
realize that their doom is inevitable, and
that he, their captor, their torturer, would
decide the exact moment they slipped into
the void?
Oh, that was what he lived for - If you could
call what the Old Man did Living.
He cracked his neck and licked his teeth.
Was he salivating? All those thoughts about
pain seemed to have got him worked up. He
could feel the distant thumping of his heart.
Old, black blood pumping through the dusty
corridors of his vascular system. Synapses
booming and sparking with excitement at the
thought of plumbing new depths of human misery,
like a scholar of suffering, a pioneer of
pain. All those silly Foundation drones, with
the audacity to think they’re in control.
He’d teach them to scream again...
Meanwhile, in the control room for the Old
Man’s containment chamber, all hell was
breaking loose. Monitors on the monster’s
vitals were all spiking: Heart and brain activity
peaked, just as they always did before the
Old Man decided to get active. Cameras in
his containment chamber showed him rising
steadily to his feet, cracking his joints,
limbering up. His body started to produce
that terrible corrosive mucus at an accelerated
rate, pooling around his feet and unleashing
squalls of noxious fumes as it melted into
the floor.
Years of Foundation testing, and they still
couldn’t find any material that could withstand
that vile black slop...
As the Old Man began strolling towards the
wall, a containment specialist in the control
room grabbed a nearby phone and sounded the
alarm for the containment breach. They needed
a Mobile Task Force and every guard on site
mobilized to tackle 106 before he got into
the facility proper and started causing havoc.
They couldn’t risk it escaping, either - The
infamous incident when the Old Man escaped
for a Halloween massacre still haunted the
nightmares of many a staff member. He had
to be stopped - Now!
A small fighting force was quickly armed and
assembled, along with armor and several high-intensity
portable lights to hopefully slow the monster
down in time for them to grab a D-Class and
set up the femur breaker. By the time they
all reached the hallway they intended to use
as a choke point for the escape, the Old Man
was already half way through the outer layer
of defence, phasing through the wall with
that same terrible, manic grin he always had
when he was about to inflict terrible violence
for the sheer fun of it.
The guards and task force members trained
their lights and weapons on him. All of them
had seen terrible things on the job - the
kind of things that would saddle almost anyone
with a lifetime of trauma - but almost nothing
compared to the horror of direct engagement
during a 106 containment breach. That terrible
old coffin dodger was Hell on two legs.
When they discovered, to their horror, that
the lights didn’t seem to be slowing him
down as much as anticipated, they fell back
on Plan B: That B standing for, “Blast the
living hell out of him with everything they
had.” The personnel opened fire, pumping
round after round into his dark form. While
each gave a loud, meaty splatter, the Old
Man didn’t even flinch. When he was close
enough, all those months of lethargy gave
way to sudden, deadly speed.
In many ways, the Old Man was like a crocodile.
A fierce and intelligent ambush predator who
conserved his energy wisely. He could seem
so deceptively languid that you could easily
mistake him for something slow and harmless.
But when you got within arm’s reach, the
sudden quickness and ferocity would take you
off guard. And by then, it’s already too
late.
Within thirty seconds, the Old Man was the
only thing left alive in that hallway. All
the guards and Task Force operatives sent
to slow him down lay dead, dripping with his
black mucus. There was silence, save for the
quiet fizzing of the mucus eating into their
clothes and skin. The Old Man sighed. How
boring. He’d killed so many people now,
it all started to seem a little... Samey.
How many screams could you hear before they
all just blended into a single shrill whine?
You can get sick of even your favorite meal
if you eat it too often.
But that didn’t matter. The Old Man had
a different order of business today: He happened
to be inside an SCP Foundation containment
facility, filled with so many fascinating
specimens of non-human entities that the one
they called SCP-106 simply couldn’t wait
to torture. He’d only met a small portion
of the ones they had contained here, but given
what a fascinating experience his past attack
on his fellow anomalies was, he couldn’t
wait to meet some more.
Meanwhile, the site’s top brass did all
they could to try to mobilize a second response
to the rogue senior citizen from hell currently
strolling through their high-security containment
facility. Could they get in contact with other
Mobile Task Forces deployed in the area? Maybe
they could get Hammer Down or Samsara in on
this mess before anything got really out of
hand? The Old Man seemed more intent on something
this time, they suspected even the femur breaker
might not work in luring him back until he
claimed whatever he deemed to be his prize.
Maybe they should contact the O5 Council...
Security guards were tracking 106’s progress
through the facility via their vast networks
of security cameras. They warned any research,
administration, and janitorial staff to clear
out of his path, unless they felt like being
tortured to death. He hadn’t dragged anyone
into his pocket dimension yet, so whoever
that privilege was reserved for would probably
be getting a particular sticky experience.
They could only speculate as to the silent
beast’s intentions.
One guard noticed something. When cross-referencing
106’s movements with a map of the facility,
they were able to triangulate where he was
heading: Straight for the containment chamber
of SCP-096. The guard’s lips curled into
a slight smile, thinking, “If one of you
freaks can actually kill the other, maybe
something positive will come out of this disaster...”
The Old Man was having a stroll down memory
lane. The time prior, when he broke out of
his cell and decided to hassle his fellow
intimates was certainly eventful - He wound
up in the company of some cantankerous reptile
and a Korean fox woman, an unlikely pair if
ever there was one. After finding himself
in a room with them, he decided that they
should have a little more privacy, and dragged
them back into his pocket dimension for further
fun.
Of course, with two at once, his attention
had been a little split. They spent as much
time tussling with each other as resisting
his attempts to torment them. They’d definitely
put him through his paces that day, and he
gave far better than he got: After so many
hours of brutal mutilation, there was barely
any of the lizard left, despite its frustrating
insistence on quickly healing from so many
of its wounds. Still, it was good exercise,
even if the results had been less than satisfying.
If he could get another anomaly alone, though,
he’d be able to take his time, and really
savor the pain he caused.
Oh, that sounded heavenly...
Soon, he came upon an incredibly strange containment
chamber that quickly caught his eye: It looked
like a huge, metal cube, with no way in or
out. Not even a seam. Whatever was trapped
in there, the Old Man thought, it must be
something that even the fools at the SCP Foundation
really, truly wanted nothing to do with. But
even more so than the strange sight, it was
the sound that drew the Old Man in, tempting
him like a siren song.
It was weeping. A soft, sobbing keen that
betrayed a bottomless well of misery. Whatever
was making that crying sound had known true
despair. Or, whatever passes for true despair
before you’ve had a close encounter with
the Old Man in his pocket dimension. The Old
Man grinned, and thought, “Oh, sonny, I’ll
give you something to really cry about...”
He stepped forward and phased his way into
the metal cube. The creature was in the corner.
In contrast to that stupid lizard, this monster
was pleasingly humanoid, with, presumably,
all the familiar pain points. Splendid. The
only real difference was color and proportion:
It was far longer and ganglier than an average
human, with greyish skin and no hair anywhere
on its body. Still, it was something the Old
Man could work with. The creature didn’t
even seem to register his presence, it just
sat crumpled in the corner, weeping.
Still grinning his lunatic grin, the Old Man
approached and rested a moist hand on the
creature’s shoulder. Its pale skin began
to fizzle from the intruder’s corrosive
touch. A pool of vile sludge began spreading
out beneath his feet until the other creature
was encompassed too. Little by little, they
sank into the Old Man’s favorite place out
of the world: The Pocket Dimension, his own
personal, eternal, infinite dungeon, where
the only laws are pain and terror for all
but the Old Man himself.
Little did he know, this time, the scores
may be a little more even on that front.
There they both stood, in that terrible labyrinth
of hallways and chambers where the Old Man
had made countless lives infinitely worse
than any terrible afterlife that could follow
them, and still, this creature didn’t seem
to change its reaction. He was almost irritated
by it. And what’s more, this whole time,
the creature hadn’t even turned to look
at him. He’d have to fix that, too.
The Old Man, with his shocking strength, gripped
the monster’s shoulder and whipped him around,
staring into his face, bearing his black eyes
and manic smile. But he couldn’t help find
what looked back at him... Disconcerting.
Its eyes were blank and white. Its face, stretched
and warped into a permanent grimace, like
Munch’s old painting, The Scream. And the
second the Old Man laid eyes on it, that’s
exactly what it did. Its gaping mouth let
out the most terrible wail the Old Man had
ever heard in all his years of torturing.
It was a scream of unknowable sadness and
fear. But somehow, the Old Man sensed that
this creature didn’t fear him. It feared
itself. Feared what it was about to do. What
the hell had he dragged down here with him?
Without warning, the terrible wails soon gave
way to sudden and ferocious aggression - Just
like the Old Man had dealt out to a group
of Foundation guards and Mobile Task Force
agents earlier that same night. It was only
out of a mix of pure luck and his own finely-tuned
animal instinct that the Old Man was able
to dodge the first strike from the creature’s
long, lithe forelimb.
He couldn’t believe it. They were in his
special place, and this victim of his had
the audacity to fight back? Well, he’d soon
put this monster in its place...
As the monster continued roaring and swiping
for him, the Old Man simply walked backwards
into a nearby wall, disappearing into a black
stain. Of course, the monster - better known
to the SCP Foundation As SCP-096, or The Shy
Guy, simply crashed through the wall to give
chase. But on the other side... Just another
wall. He’d disappeared. How?
Typically, when something sees the face of
the Shy Guy, he immediately has a kind of
intuitive connection to them. He can sense
their presence, it’s burned into his mind,
a homing beacon, an unstoppable imperative.
He knows exactly where they are and how to
get to them. But nothing about this situation
was typical. The Shy Guy felt all the murderous
rage he normally did, but the rest was just
static. Where was the life he needed to abolish
hiding?
Suddenly, the Old Man emerged behind him,
and forced his hand into the Shy Guy’s back.
His fist melted straight through flesh and
skin, causing the creature to let out another
terrible wail, but as could be expected, they
didn’t leave a scratch on the Shy Guy’s
indestructible skeleton.
The Shy Guy pulled a one-eighty and swung
for the Old Man again, but he was already
gone. Here in the Pocket Dimension, the Old
Man had the ultimate home-turf advantage.
Here, space and time were his playthings.
In the infinite twisting, labyrinthine walls
of the Pocket Dimension, the Old Man wasn’t
just the Devil, he was God, too.
But it would take far more than some cheap
tricks and bodily harm to dissuade the Shy
Guy from his sole purpose in life. It began
running through the Old Man’s personal maze
like a crazed lab rat, tearing through wall
after wall, forever searching for the monster
that trapped it here. It would see the smiling
face of that rotten old man every so often,
the flash of black eyes and dirty teeth in
shadows, but every time it tried to strike
the shadows, there would be nothing there.
And every time he got a chance, the Old Man
would emerge from the shadows behind the Shy
Guy to strike back, clawing into his flesh
and vanishing again before the trapped beast
could retaliate. The nasty old sadist was
now starting to have some fun: It was a reflex
test, a classic game of high-stakes Whack
A Mole. And every time the creature failed
to strike him, its distress only seemed to
grow. This was perfectly fine for the Old
Man.
After all, he enjoyed a little mental torment
as much as he loved physical torture, and
a human would have died or given in to despair
long before now. This monster’s wonderful
mix of resilience and pain made it a great
chew toy.
The Old Man kept up this routine, baiting
and striking, until something unanticipated
happened. He appeared, waited for the swing,
disappeared as it approached, then reappeared
behind the Shy Guy to deliver another painful
strike. This time, however, it seemed his
victim had anticipated his pattern. Before
he could hit the creature, the Shy Guy turned,
quicker than anything the Old Man had ever
seen, and hit him with such force he flew
through several walls in his own maze, shattering
them as he went.
He hit the ground, stunned by the fact the
Shy Guy had actually landed a hit, but he
wasn’t done. The shrieking monster came
bounding after him. Before the Old Man could
stand, it struck him again, and again, and
again, pounding his vile body into the ground,
which cracked and crumbled. The Old Man sneered
and sank into a puddle of his mucus on the
ground.
The Old Man was gone again. SCP-096 screamed
in a mix of rage, despair, and frustration,
so consumed with its hunt that it didn’t
notice the pool of corrosive mucus was slowly
growing. It began to rise, bubbling and hissing
at SCP-096’s feet. Getting deeper and deeper
and deeper, as the walls rose taller and taller
around it. The creature wailed, until a tide
of the awful stuff reached its face and cascaded
down its throat, melting all the organs within.
As the creature was fully submerged, SCP-106
manifested atop the wall, and looked down,
smiling spitefully.
He thought, oh, you may think you had me there,
boy-o, but in the end, I always win. Nothing
could survive that!
And yet, bubbles still rose from the slop
below. The Old Man gritted his rotten teeth
and balled his fists in quiet anger.
Moments later, back in our dimension, a portal
opened in the ground of SCP-096’s containment
chamber. It vomited out SCP-096’s skeleton,
smothered in bubbling black goo, and SCP-106.
096 would probably be fully regenerated within
a couple of hours - and if 682’s encounter
with him was anything to go by, probably extremely
unwilling to interface with the Old Man. And
the Old Man himself, who couldn’t help but
feel a little humiliated by the whole experience,
was glad the two of them would probably never
meet again.
He left the regenerating 096 and commenced
the walk of shame back to his containment
chamber. They didn’t even need the femur
breaker, he just felt like having a sit-down
and processing it all. Nobody else would ever
know what happened in the pocket dimension
that day, and for the Old Man’s pride, that
was probably for the best. But he’d know.
He’d always know.
By the night’s end, he was sitting in his
containment chamber again, forlornly wondering,
“Goddamn it, old-timer, have you lost your
edge?”
What do you do, when the sun turns wrong?
When light, which once represented life, joy,
and warmth becomes a symbol of death and destruction?
Do you hide inside, shutter the windows, keep
out the light by any means necessary? Do you
retreat underground, where the sun’s rays
cannot penetrate, burrowing into the dark
and the cold? Do you simply give yourself
to it, accept that there is no escaping something
so vast, so far-reaching as sunlight itself,
and allow yourself to be lost in the end of
all things?
We’ve covered this possibility before, SCP-001,
“When Day Breaks”, or S.D. Locke’s Proposal.
It’s difficult to know what any given person
might do in such harrowing circumstances.
After all, we have always learned to love
the light and fear the darkness. It turns
our very understanding of reality upside down
to have that paradigm shifted, the dark becoming
safety and the light becoming death. The source
of all life on earth, of all warmth, transforming
in an instant from the sun as we know it to
an Apollyon Class SCP that melts all living
organisms that cross into its gaze.
But what about a being that has always feared
the light? Something that prioritizes solitude,
and never ever wants to be seen? How might
it live out those darkened days?
Today, we’re taking a look at what happens
when Daybreak meets a familiar face, even
if a constantly hidden one: SCP-096.
SCP-096, or “The Shy Guy,” is something
of a celebrity around here. It is a humanoid
creature with long, distended arms, pale skin,
and a jaw that can open four times wider than
an ordinary human’s. There is only one thing,
above all else, that this entity desires:
for no one to see its face. When someone views
its face, it flies into an uncontrollable
rage, and seems to have no other option but
to destroy the person who has seen it.
So, it is unlikely that a creature so intent
on solitude would be in much danger from the
transformed sun. In fact, it might even be
a positive thing, and for some time it was.
With so many human beings gone, reduced to
gelatinous masses with no desire but to slither
around in the ghoulish sunlight and merge
with one another, there were fewer people
to observe his face than ever. He could stay
inside and know, with almost complete certainty,
that no one would come to bother him. No one
was coming to look at him, and there were
no more visitors, researchers poking and prodding,
that might sneak a look at his face.
And so, he stayed there, in the room that
had served as his containment unit before
the world turned upside down. The masses of
flesh that once were humans did not concern
him, as they never looked at his face. All
he did was stay in his room, and never go
outside. The outside frightened him terribly,
though he was not concerned with the deadly
sunlight or the possibility of it melting
him as it had so many others. He was much
more afraid that someone, some unlikely survivor
clinging to their original life, might look
at him. That they might see his face. That
was simply too distressing to risk. He would
much rather stay alone, in his old cell, weeping
softly in the shadows.
One day, though we couldn’t say how many
days after the end of things it had been,
he was weeping alone in his former cell. The
days blurred together, spent the same way,
and time had lost much of its meaning. Through
the echoing sound of his sobs, and the sloshing
sounds of the creatures outside, a woman’s
voice cut through. It was faint, but he could
make out what she was saying. She was calling
out for help, asking if anyone had any food
or fresh water. The sound was getting louder,
closer, accompanied by the disconcerting thump
of her footsteps. She was coming down the
hall, as much as it could be called a hall
anymore. She was coming toward his room, to
disrupt his miserable peace.
He heard her steps cross the threshold of
his room, and her voice broke into a terrified
scream, no doubt at the unexpected sight of
a pale, naked creature weeping in the corner
of what she expected to be an empty room.
Startled by the first loud sound he’d heard
in a long time, in a world that had mostly
been silent since the initial outpouring of
agonized screams had faded into the soft slap
of flesh and slime on the ground, he turned
around.
He shouldn’t, ordinarily he wouldn’t,
but he couldn’t stop himself. There, he
saw a woman, wide eyes filled with tears,
face streaked with dirt, a small child next
to her holding her hand and clinging to her
leg. Just as he saw the woman, she saw him.
She saw…his face. Anger boiled over inside
of him, and he let out a scream, wild, primal,
and filled with inhuman rage. She could not
be looking at him, seeing his face. He couldn’t
let her.
The woman ran with the child in tow, panicked
by the wild roar and the sight of him standing
upright before her. The anger faded as she
left his site, making her way down the hall
and to the stairs. But then, he remembered:
she had seen his face. He could not let her
leave. It was time to do something he never
thought he’d have to do again: hunt. His
heightened senses picked up the sound of muffled
footsteps, coming up through the floor below
him. She was downstairs, just beneath the
floor where he was standing.
His instincts kicked in, and his body moved
almost of its own accord. He lifted his long,
long arms above his head, and drove his hands
down into the floor. It was weakened by the
ravages of the elements and time, and crumbled
under his unnatural strength. He dug his claws
into the plaster, tearing it apart and cracking
it into pieces. He pushed his claws in, deeper
and deeper, until he could feel them breaking
through to the other side. He pulled the floor
apart until the hole was wide enough to fit
through, then dropped down to the room below.
He spotted the woman’s back, fleeing through
the door, just as he landed.
She was getting away!
He tore after her, ripping through concrete
and steel, destroying everything in his path
in a mad dash for the object of his rage.
He had to catch her, she could not be allowed
to leave. She looked over her shoulder at
him, her face a mask of pure terror. She knew,
just as he knew, that there was no escape
in sight. In his single-minded obsession,
and her desperation to escape from him, neither
of them noticed that she had run so far and
so carelessly that she was now outside of
the building. She had crossed from the shadows,
into the harsh light of the sun.
The woman’s eyes widened in grim understanding
of her fate. He could only watch, helplessly,
as her body began to succumb to the vicious
rays. Almost instantly, she began to melt.
As it was the closest to the sun, her head
was the first to go. Her nose drooped like
hot wax, dripping as it went until it slumped
off her face and landed on the ground with
a sickening splash. Her eyes were next, popping
out of their sockets and hanging, loose and
limp, on her cheeks and dangling from sinewy
strands.
She tried, in vain, to stuff them back into
place, but they squished in her hands like
overripe fruit. She attempted to run into
the comparative safety of the ruined building,
but her feet were already beginning to spread
out onto the street, melting into a sticky
red smear on the pavement. Her legs crumbled
beneath her, and she collapsed to the ground,
her face leaving a trail of gelatinous flesh
as it landed.
She tried, uselessly, to drag herself along
the ground back into the darkness, but her
arms were melting into the dirt, mixing with
it into a horrible red mud. She let out a
last scream of agony, but the sound turned
to a thick gurgle as her lips fused together
and her mouth melted into nothingness. He
watched it all, sobbing and roaring in frustration.
She was gone, and he would never get the satisfaction
of ending her. The infernal sun had stolen
her from him. Now she was nothing but a wet
shadow, like the rest of the humans had become
long ago.
He heard the sound of a soft sob behind him,
a tiny human voice. He turned, looking for
the source. There, was the little girl. He
had almost forgotten about her. She was calling
out for her mother and crying, and she was
looking right at him. Right at his face. He
waited for the anger to overtake him, but
instead…there was nothing. Why wasn’t
he angry? She was looking at his face, so
why? Then he realized: her eyes were on him,
but she did not see him. She was blind.
She approached the creature, her arms outstretched,
following the sound of his crying. She touched
his hand with her own tiny fingers, so small
and fragile, and asked, “Mommy?” Then,
he felt something he had never felt before.
Tenderness, care, a desire to protect this
tiny innocent being. It was the first time
he had ever felt warm, ever felt anything
but sadness, anger, or fear. Overcome with
this softness, he wrapped his arms around
the child and hugged her close. She hugged
him back, tightly, and the room went quiet
as they both stopped crying.
From that day on, they became a family of
sorts. They lived together, and he took care
of her. She didn’t know what he looked like,
and had no idea he might be something to fear.
To her, he was safety. He was home. For the
first time in his long, awful life, he felt
like a human instead of a monster. He would
scavenge food for her, bring her fresh water,
lay down stolen blankets and pillows so she
would have a soft place to rest. He even found
her a ratty, worn teddy bear amongst the rubble
and gave it to her as a gift.
She clutched it to her chest and thanked him,
and for once his tears were those of joy.
In this cursed world, they had found something
like happiness in one another. He knew he
would protect her no matter what.
Then, one day, everything changed. The creature
and the little girl were playing in the abandoned
site, making up little games together, when
he took a break to look out the window and
monitor their surroundings. Outside, the evil
red sun waited. When he turned back, the little
girl was gone. One of the shadowy creatures,
once human, was imitating his voice to lure
her away. He could hear it in the distance,
and her tiny footsteps following it.
He chased after her, the only thing he had
ever loved, and saw her just as she stepped
out into the light. She screamed as one of
her arms began to melt in the light, and he
knew what he had to do. He grabbed her and
pulled her back inside, using his body to
shield her from the horrible rays. As he wept
over her, his tears stopped her body from
melting any further, but his body continued
to fall apart. It was too late for him.
He ran, as far away as he could. Once he transformed,
he did not want to end up hurting the girl.
He ran until his legs melted away and he could
not run anymore. He had reached the shoreline,
and stared out at the ocean, unable to move
any more.
He screamed, a final time, in agony, in heartbreak,
in mourning for the happiness he had finally
found and now would lose. But at least he
knew, as his eyes melted away and he was nearly
gone, that the girl would be safe. And then,
he was gone, and the world was quiet.
A very strange anomaly sits in a humanoid
containment cell in the minimum security wing
of Site 17. He walks, talks, and looks like
a man, but everything else is convoluted in
a question mark. This is SCP-343 - Who, like
his namesake, God, is likely to cause arguments
whenever he’s brought up. Is he the creator
of all that exists? The basis for the Abrahamic
Faiths? Or is he a pretender - A reality warper
with immense power and a predilection towards
delusion? A courtesan of the House of Malidraug?
Matthew? Methuselah? Yahweh?
Who knows? Really, it depends on who you ask,
and which stories you choose to believe. And
few people enjoy a good story more than SCP-343
himself. If, one day, you take the time to
visit him in his room, and ask him to reveal
a page in the long book of his personal history,
he might be kind enough to tell you a story.
A story like this - Of an encounter with something
monstrous, that few others could hope to survive
meeting face to face…
Rewind a few thousand years. Nobody knows
how many, exactly. God - as he chooses to
dub himself - walked across the cracked ground
on worn sandals. It’d been some time since
he’d seen an animal around here, and even
longer since he’d seen a human being. Not
that this bothered him. He’d never been
bothered by his own company on a long walk
like this.
Of course, he could have sped up time or teleported,
but where was the fun in that? He was a tourist
in the world of sensation. Of experience.
Of flesh, bone, dirt, blood, and sand. After
all, where’s the fun in creating a whole
universe if you can’t drop in now and then
to visit and do as the Romans do? Not that
the Romans would be around for another few
thousand years. Even Atlas must occasionally
shift the weight of the globe from his shoulders
for a jaunt around the cosmic neighborhood,
and whatever passes for “fresh air” in
the vacuum.
God whistled a tune to himself. It was a craggy,
mountainous region he’d found himself in.
The distant peaks had frosted caps. A breathtaking
place, where many truly had their breaths
taken away. How humans will so happily risk
their lives to do something extraordinary.
It never ceased to amaze him.
His stomach rumbled. Oh, how he enjoyed that
sensation. One of the funny little quirks
of this human form that he’d weaved for
himself. It was no reason to be concerned
- If memory served, from his last trip through
the area a few decades before, there was a
friendly village not far from here. They had
always accepted him as a genial stranger,
having no knowledge of his true power. God
had always believed that a person’s goodness
is defined by how they treat those from whom
they had nothing to gain.
So it caused him great concern as he approached
the village, and saw great plumes of smoke
rising into the sky. He was so shocked by
this that he decided to break his rule about
walking as a man, in case there was still
some way he could help. With a snap of his
fingers, he disappeared and reappeared in
the center of the village’s town square.
Total devastation. Huts and houses had been
torn asunder. Broken weapons lay on the ground.
Some places were on fire, others smeared with
streaks of blood, like some terrible battle
had occurred here. But something was wrong.
No bodies. Not one, from defender or assailant.
How could a thriving village be so thoroughly
destroyed, and not leave a single corpse?
It was an act so bizarre and depraved that
it even left God puzzling.
That was another downside of his human form:
Here, on earth, he didn’t have access to
true omniscience. How could a mere human mind,
bound by the constraints of linear time, ever
truly comprehend the totality of existence?
Even attempting to do that here would melt
the brain of his human body in its skull,
and leave it dribbling out of his nose and
ears.
Instead, he chose to walk around the ruins
of the village and investigate firsthand.
Arrows and broken spears and swords littered
the ground. Some buildings were demolished,
but there were no tracks or stray projectiles
that could suggest the presence of siege weapons.
No, these buildings looked like they were
ripped apart. Some even still had claw marks…
What terrible beast could have set upon this
town and done this?
Then, he heard a voice, quiet and pleading
beneath some nearby rubble. A survivor! He
rushed over to the pile and evaporated it
with a thought, Underneath, a feeble old man,
covered in stone dust, was quivering. God
helped him up and guided him into one of the
few remaining huts still standing in the village.
They both took seats - God held up two hands,
cradling empty space. Two cups suddenly occupied
that space, both filled with warm, healing
tea. He passed the old man one of the cups
while sipping from his own.
He asked the old man if he’d seen what had
happened. The old man told him, no, he hadn’t
seen anything in decades. He’d been rendered
blind in his youth. Little did either of them
know, that very blindness was the only reason
he was the sole survivor of the massacre.
The blind man told God that one of the village’s
scouts had gone up into the mountain with
a small hunting party. The group was gone
for days, until one of the members - the youngest
among them - returned, weeping, frostbitten,
and covered in blood. He said that his friends
had been killed by a beast in the mountains.
Something that looked almost like a man, but
terribly wrong. And its face. Its awful, awful
face. He would never forget it. He was just
lucky to escape with his life when the others
were torn apart.
But when the young man returned, he’d brought
the shadow of death with him. It was a curse
that doomed the entire village - men, women,
and children - to a terrible fate. And that
fate was upon them a mere hour after the survivor
had returned.
Of course, there were gaps in the blind man’s
understanding, given he was lacking one of
his major senses. But the sounds he could
describe with perfect clarity. It was faint
and distant at first. That awful wail, and
the galloping. Hands and feet thundering against
the ground, faster than any horse could move.
Getting closer and closer and closer.
Another villager saw it approaching and screamed,
then it was upon them. The villagers screamed
but it screamed louder. Always wailing and
shrieking and sobbing like a monster crawled
straight up from hell. People tried to fight
it, by the sounds of it. The blind man, with
teary, blank eyes, recalled the sounds of
arrows nocking and swords clashing against…
Something. But even their greatest warriors
had screamed and died. Those who saw it and
tried to flee and hide were slaughtered all
the same. Soon enough, there were only two
sounds left in the village. The monster and
the blind man, both weeping.
He didn’t understand why it never took him.
It wasn’t fair. It took everything else.
To leave him here, alive, when everyone and
everything he’d ever known was destroyed,
was a greater punishment than even death.
After killing all of these innocents, the
monster had simply wandered off to the mountains
again, the sound of its quiet sobs getting
smaller and smaller until it was gone altogether.
God comforted the blind man as he wept for
the loss of all his loved ones. He told the
blind man that he would venture up to the
mountains himself and confront the creature
on its own territory, and, at the very least,
find out why it had done this terrible thing.
But first, he must relocate the blind man
to a safer place.
He placed a hand on the blind man’s shoulder
and he vanished. He would appear in another
friendly village, miles away. God sent a silent
message into the minds of every villager:
Take good care of this man. He has undergone
horrors you can’t even imagine. Your kindness
will be rewarded later, for that, you have
my promise.
God sighed and turned his tired eyes to the
distant mountains. A monster lurked up there
- Perhaps one of his own creations, or maybe
a corruption of one of his creations. Either
way, whatever existed without his knowledge
existed without his consent, and he intended
to know of the beast in the mountains. Though
given what he’d seen already, he didn’t
expect to receive a warm welcome from this
murderous demon.
Miles away, up in the mountains, the creature
licked the blood from its cracked lips. It
looked like it might once have been a human
being or something that aspired to humanity,
or mocked it with its very existence. It was
a huge, gangling beast, skin alabaster, eyes
empty and soulless, dribbling rivulets of
burning tears down a hideous, gaunt face.
It crawled into the frozen mouth of a cave
with great icicle fangs, wheezing and weeping.
All it ever wanted was to be alone. Why did
they have to keep interfering? Didn’t they
know what happened? All the terrible things
they’d made it do…
The creature curled its long, gangly body
into the fetal position, scratching great
ruts into the sides of its bald cranium with
long, sharp fingers. Terrible things. Terrible,
terrible things…
And then there was a brilliant flash, just
a few feet away. The monster was surprised,
it turned to see a figure silhouetted in the
mouth of the cave. He wore sandals and thin
robes. His eyes glowed with a kind of power
that the monster didn’t recognize. This
stranger stared at the monster without an
ounce of fear in his heart: He stared right
into its eyes, unwavering.
No! No, no, no, no! It could feel it again.
The rage bubbling up, deep down. A cauldron
of seething anger. It hated the feeling, like
being lowered into a vat of molten metal.
Unspeakable fire and pain coursing through
every vessel. It began to weep and scream
while the stranger in the cave mouth just
watched, not moving a muscle.
“Do you know who I am?” the stranger asked
with a deep voice that betrayed almost infinite
power, knowledge, and wisdom. But it wouldn’t
change the outcome here.
The monster bounded at him at speeds that
wouldn’t be seen again until jet planes
and bullet trains are invented millennia into
the future. Its jaws were hanging impossibly
wide, fangs borne, its arms extended and deadly
claws ready to strike. But before those terrible
hands could close around the stranger, he
vanished. The monster stumbled and rolled
across the snow, confused. What trickery was
being used here?
“I’ll take that as a no,” said the voice
from behind him. “You ought to show your
father some respect. More respect than you
gave to those poor people down in the village,
at least.”
Seething, the creature turned and saw the
stranger standing back in the darkness of
the cave, staring at him. But the beast didn’t
have the capacity for awe or holy terror.
Only violence. Boundless, limitless, unstoppable
violence.
It darted towards the stranger again, trying
to strike at him. Somehow, it was like fighting
an empty robe. Not a single one of its deadly
strikes seemed to hit the stranger. The stranger
leaped backwards, putting some space between
himself and the monster but still not breaking
a sweat. He breathed in deeply, then exhaled.
The breath came out like a mighty typhoon,
shocking even the monster with its sudden
force. It was blown backwards, a leaf in the
wind, until its long claws dug into the ground
and anchored it in place. The stranger gave
a wry smile at this, impressed.
“My, my, you’re certainly a tenacious
one, aren’t you?” he said. “Perhaps
we can talk for a little while instead of
fighting. I want to know why you killed all
those people.”
No answer. The beast roared, its mighty limbs
pounding into the ground as it closed the
gap between itself and the stranger in fractions
of a second. It would kill him. Rend him.
Destroy him just like all the others. He’d
left it no choice!
Suddenly, the ground below it seemed to give
away. The creature was confused. It looked
down to see that the ancient stone below had
somehow taken on the properties of a liquid,
and it was sinking. The beast panicked and
began to thrash. It was a strong swimmer,
but it didn’t expect to need to swim here.
The shock was too much, and soon, the ground
submerged it entirely, muffling its terrible
roars and shrieks.
And just like that, the ground was solid again,
trapping the beast inside.
The stranger stepped forward and looked at
the ground. “A much-needed time out,”
he said. “You do yourself no good struggling
like this.”
Despite its terrible capacity for evil, God
couldn’t help but admire the beast, at least
on the level of construction. It was so pared
down, so unburdened. A killer to the core,
but seemingly unkillable. Had he made this
creature? Billions of species and the species
those, in turn, had created through billions
of years of breeding and evolution, and somewhere
along the line, this thing happened. It was
easy even for the universe’s creator to
lose track of some of the tinier variables.
And in the grand scheme of things, even this
monster was still a tiny variable. But right
here, right now, it was still one hell of
a problem.
The ground rumbled below God. Cracks formed.
The mountain peak shook. God raised an eyebrow,
genuinely impressed, as the monster ripped
free of its stone prison and re-entered the
fray. It roared and screamed still, its blank
eyes fixed on him. Its skeletal body throbbed
and heaved with power. Unlike any other creature
in nature, it was almost like, the longer
their conflict went on, the more energized
the beast became.
God sighed. All those poor villagers. They
never stood a chance against this monster.
It lunged for him, even faster and stronger
than before. He teleported out of the way
in the nick of time and the beast’s claws
cleaved through a nearby cave wall, effortless.
God materialized nearby, but he didn’t have
time to speak. The beast lunged again, and
again, and again. Every time he reappeared,
the beast went for him with impossible speed.
Deciding to widen the playing field, God teleported
to the top of the mountain. The creature,
somehow sensing his presence, vaulted upwards
and tunneled through the roof of the cave,
bursting out of the ground in front of God,
who was floating just slightly off the ground.
“It would be wise of you to stop,” God
carefully intoned. “All this time, you know,
I’ve been going easy on you. You don’t
want to find out what the wrath of God looks
like.”
Storm clouds were gathering above. Mighty
thunder roared across the sky. The beast was
undeterred. It roared and galloped towards
God. And God, in turn, called down a response.
A volley of lightning the likes of which the
world has never seen before or since struck
down on the charging monster. The sudden white
flash could sting the eyes from miles away.
The monster shrieked from the blast, feeling
its flesh lift off its bones and atomize in
the sheer heat of the electricity around it.
It could smell itself cooking. The lightning
blasts only lasted for a few seconds, but
for the beast, it felt like an eternity.
When the onslaught stopped, the air was still
heavy with electrical potential. God stared
down at the black scorch mark on the side
of the mountain where the creature had been
standing. All the snow within the mile had
been evaporated by the blast. It was a raw
display of the power of nature that would
make even Zeus tremble in his sandals.
And yet… There was still movement. Something
started to get up from the burnt patch where
nothing should be left alive. A blackened
skeleton, rising shakily from the ash but
still very much alive. As it started to rise,
new flesh began growing over the bones, little
by little. Even God was astonished by the
sight of it. He’d never seen a creature
cling so ardently to life in spite of having
truly unsurmountable power amassed against
it.
It was up against God, and still, it fought.
The monster tottered on its freakishly long
limbs, still disoriented, unusually staggered
for a creature driven by such single-minded,
violent purpose. When enough of its face grew
back to do so, it began to weep and sob again,
tears streaking down its terrible face. Looking
at this creature, after all this, God couldn’t
help but feel a new emotion: Pity.
He lowered himself to the ground and approached
the creature. Like none had ever done before,
he gathered it up into his arms and held it,
feeling its heaving, wretched sobs against
him. This beast was in so much pain. He could
feel it, radiating from within.
“Speak, my son,” God said in a soft, fatherly
voice.
And for the first and only time, the monster
spoke, “Can’t look. Can’t see. Make
me hurt people. Don’t want hurt people.
Can’t look, can’t look. Please.”
That was all it managed to choke out before
devolving back into unintelligible babble.
But it was enough. Enough for God to understand
its pain. He did not know if it would be right
to change the monster’s nature - is it ever
right to truly change anyone’s nature? - but
it was within his almost limitless power to
grant it one reprieve from its pain.
He settled the beast in the snow below him.
It was quiet and still.
And God said unto the beast, “Rest now,
child. Rest for thousands of years, if you
must. I hope only that when you eventually
awaken, you feel differently…”
And so another story from the catalog of SCP-343.
Of course, it leaves us with certain questions,
chief among them being: Is it true? Did 343
and 096 have this chance encounter long ago,
or is this just another tall tale from an
anomaly who fancies himself a deity? We have
our truth, and you have yours
If you’ve been a close follower of this
channel for a while now, or even of the SCP
Foundation Archive as a whole, then there’s
a pretty high chance that you might have heard
of SCP-096. Even if this just so happens to
be the first of our SCP videos that you’ve
ever clicked on, you still might have seen
the Shy Guy itself in various other corners
of the internet. Since the earliest days of
the SCP Foundation, SCP-096 has gradually
become one of the most iconic and recognizable
creatures in the Foundation’s entire menagerie
of anomalous beings.
Despite standing taller than any ordinary
person, you might be forgiven for mistaking
SCP-096 for a human being if you were to see
it at a distance. But the creature is unusually
proportioned, to say the least, still appearing
almost human in its shape, but possessing
long, dangling arms that almost reach the
ground. SCP-096’s body is thin and hairless,
with opaque, clear white pupil-less eyes and
a wide, gaping mouth - or so we’ve heard,
thanks to drawings provided by someone who
sadly isn’t with us anymore...
But you might be surprised to learn that SCP-096
doesn’t really do all that much. Mostly,
the tall, spindly humanoid spends its waking
days mindlessly pacing around in its containment
cell. Sounds like most days in a college dorm
during lockdown, right? That is, of course,
until someone dares to look at SCP-096’s
face. It doesn’t have to be directly either,
it can be something as simple as glancing
at a photo, or watching a video of the creature.
But the moment it is seen, the exact second
it’s perceived, the wiry monster will know.
Having its face viewed in any way will cause
the Shy Guy to really live up to its nickname;
the creature suffers some sort of psychological
meltdown, covering its face with its huge,
claw-like hands and weeping. SCP-096 quickly
becomes utterly inconsolable, suffering from
extreme emotional distress until it simply
can’t take it anymore. Pulling itself up
to its full, looming height, SCP-096 will
stand and travel at impossible speeds towards
the person that dared look at its face.
There’s no way to hide from the Shy Guy,
nothing can stand in its path as it tracks
down this unlucky person. And when it finds
them? Well, it’s certainly not pleasant.
Somehow, without leaving any trace on their
body, SCP-096 will kill the person that looked
at it, possibly even eating them afterwards.
Then, it calms itself down, returns to its
more docile state, and is typically bagged
and brought back home by whatever Mobile Task
Force is closest.
SCP-096 has killed many of the teams sent
to contain it, proving itself to be resistant
to gunfire and other forms of conventional
weaponry. As much as being only a little as
a tiny speck in a photograph is enough to
trigger the creature’s relentless defense
mechanism. Nobody can get away from it either,
there is literally nowhere in the entire world
that someone can run to escape SCP-096. Not
even crossing the oceans or jumping aboard
a plane is enough to stop it. And if our community
questions video on the matter is anything
to go by, you may not even be safe in outer
space.
The SCP Foundation’s only real way to keep
the creature safely under wraps and contained
is to lock it up and force all members of
personnel to never, ever look at it, while
they hunt down any pieces of recorded media
still out there, waiting like a ticking time
bomb.
So, if no member of the Foundation can look
at SCP-096, how do they interact with it?
Well, luckily, there’s a tale that answers
exactly that, known as “A Lesson in Power.”
Doctor Danielle Kowalski, a member of the
Foundation’s research team assigned to SCP-096,
was sent into the creature’s cell wearing
a sleep mask. You know, the kind you get on
expensive flights? What she was really wishing
for though, was a gas mask to go with it;
Nobody had warned her how bad SCP-096 smelled.
Then again though, few had been as close to
the creature as she had and lived to tell
the tale.
As a child, Danielle Kowalski had a fear of
stepping into the ocean. Her mother used to
warn her about treading on a stingray and
dying as a result, giving her a phobia that
stayed with her for many years. But Danielle’s
father had encouraged her to face her fear,
to shuffle her feet on the ocean floor, kicking
up the sand so that the stingrays would know
she was coming, and would simply just swim
away.
Perhaps if he could have seen what kind of
horrors Danielle would be working with at
the Foundation, her father wouldn’t have
tried to make her so fearless. Maybe there
are some things that it’s logical to be
afraid of.
Entering SCP-096’s cell, Doctor Kowalski
could hear the monster’s heaving breaths,
the perfect mix between a frightened whimper
and a death rattle, the haunting sound of
a person’s final gasp of air. In the back
of her mind, Danielle hoped she didn’t touch
the creature by accident. The closer she got,
the tension and the heat of its warm breath
against her skin was making the approach all
the more terrifying. She had been issued with
an instant camera, and took a photo in the
dark. Click. The flash fired, but with her
eyes covered she couldn’t tell.
That was good though, that was the point.
If Danielle could see the flash going off,
she could see what else was in the room, and
that would put her in even more danger. She
was locked in with a kind of stingray that
wouldn’t swim away, even if it knew she
was there.
Slowly, Doctor Kowalski began blindly photographing
the cell around her, stuffing each freshly
printed photo into her pocket as the camera
spat them out. Over the span of forty-five
minutes, she took a series of pictures of
the entire cell, until the film in the instant
camera had run out. Danielle knew that she
would probably only need one picture, but
better to have more, just in case. Luckily,
none of her Foundation colleagues were around
to tell her how insane what she was doing
was. They were all preoccupied, preparing
the site for its first official visit from
the FBI.
This all took place after what was known as
the Broken Masquerade had taken place. Essentially,
knowledge of the SCP Foundation and its research
into the endless stream of anomalies it had
contained was all made public. People knew
the truth now, and the Foundation found itself
in the one place it never wanted to be: the
public eye.
The organization and its activities were under
the scrutiny of every journalist on the planet,
and once more information about the SCPs and
the anomalous world of the Foundation became
known, the world would surely change forever.
Danielle Kowalski knew all of this and told
herself that everyone would need something
for protection now. She only hoped her photographs
would be enough.
Fifteen months later, Doctor Kowalski was
interrogated in her apartment, by one Agent
O’Brien. He and a group of fellow agents
had barged into Danielle’s home, demanding
to know the location where a number of SCP-610
specimens were being held. SCP-610 being,
of course, the infamous infection known as
the Flesh that Hates, a disease capable of
turning human beings into horrible, deformed
monstrosities of flesh. Agent O’Brien, and
presumably whoever he was working for, was
intent on turning these creatures into weapons,
and the man had little patience for a former
Foundation researcher who wasn’t giving
up the answers that he wanted.
Danielle tried to argue with the Agent, citing
the Berlin Accords Against Weaponized Anomalies,
a motion proposed to the United States Senate
that would forbid the use of anomalous objects,
entities, and creatures as weapons for any
country. O’Brien wasn’t interested, he
claimed that if the Kremlin in Russia had
no intention of ratifying such a law, then
America wouldn’t either. The Agent had his
men grab Danielle by her arm, while he grabbed
her right middle finger and began to push
a thin knife under her fingernail.
The former member of the Foundation tried
to stifle her scream, but couldn’t stop
herself as the pain struck.
As Agent O’Brien tortured Danielle, he told
her that the Russians had all the information
they would need about SCP-610 in order to
turn the Flesh into some kind of weapon. As
far as he was concerned, the United States
government needed access to those SCP-610
specimens to know exactly what they would
be up against in the likely event that Russia
used the Flesh that Hates against them. And
only a researcher for the SCP Foundation,
the former senior researcher of the SCP-610
project, would know where to find those specimens.
“You don't think it's reasonable for the
United States government to want to understand
what could be used against us?” O’Brien
asked as Danielle’s blood trickled out of
her finger into his leather gloves. “Hell,
I don't care what you think we're going to
do with it. I want those specimens.”
When the Agent finally let her go, Doctor
Kowalski tried to catch her breath, forcing
herself not to scream in pain again. She pointed
with her other, unharmed hand, to her bedroom,
telling O’Brien to check the bottom left
drawer. She had placed a manilla envelope
in there, containing the only thing Danielle
had kept since departing the SCP Foundation.
Under O’Brien’s order, his men ransacked
the nearby room and were quickly able to find
what they were looking for.
The envelope was presented to Agent O’Brien,
who was no doubt expecting to find a file
inside, something that detailed the exact
location of those specimens he was looking
for. So, you can probably imagine the dissatisfied
look on his face when he opened the envelope
to find… photographs. A collection of instant
photos, all taken in a dark cell, with all
of them depicting a tall, thin humanoid creature.
A being with long, dangling arms that almost
reached the ground, a thin, hairless body,
opaque, pupil-less eyes, and a wide, gaping
mouth.
Furious to once again be denied the information
he was looking for, O’Brien disregarded
the pictures and burned Doctor Kowalski’s
neck with his cigarette.
In his anger, he said “I think your Foundation
sure thought they were powerful hiding in
the shadows. But I'd like to explain to you
why you're wrong.” The Agent then went on
to describe his time as a member of the DEA
in the late 1980’s, and how he’d been
involved in the hunting of notorious cartel
boss Pablo Escobar.
“I had a narco in custody… every bit as
uncooperative as you are now.” The man had
insisted that Escobar owned all of the Colombian
law enforcement, but a younger O’Brien had
argued that, if that was the case and they
possessed all this power, then why did Pablo
Escobar’s men hide their guns? Why smuggle
drugs in secret, and bury their money where
no one would find it if they really had the
control they claimed?
Much like Escobar’s cartel, the SCP Foundation
had always moved in the shadows, a power that
O’Brien believed to have really belonged
to the government. “Your anomalies belong
to us. Your research belongs to us. Your life
belongs to us,” he told Doctor Kowalski.
Suddenly, one of the other agents noticed
movement outside the apartment. The second
that Danielle saw a long arm phase through
her wall, with grey skin like that of a corpse,
she snapped her eyes shut. O’Brien and his
men all drew their guns and opened fire on
the monster that had walked through the wall
as if it wasn’t even there.
All the while, Danielle Kowalski kept her
eyes shut. The sounds of screaming and snapping
bones and a sickening slurping noise filled
the air, but she made sure not to look. Within
a few quick moments of panic and agonizing
pain, it was over. The apartment was quiet,
apart from strange breathing; like a mix of
a frightened whimper and a death rattle.
“Run along now, 096,” Doctor Kowalski
told the Shy Guy. “There are worse monsters
in this world than you.”
Dr. Dan anxiously paced his cell. It was the
only way he’d been able to occupy himself
for the past six months, save for poring through
files and, when he was lucky, being able to
oversee another failed termination attempt.
He only stopped pacing when, for a brief and
horrible moment, he realized that monster
was probably doing the exact same thing in
its big, metal cube at this very moment. That
horrible creature that he’d thrown away
his life for a futile shot at killing.
Perhaps the whole thing had been a fool’s
errand. After all, he was formerly a researcher
under the employ of the SCP Foundation. Secure,
Contain, Protect. They had truly sadistic
beasts like SCP-106, the nightmarish Old Man,
and SCP-352, Baba Yaga, in containment cells,
and there were no plans to terminate either
of them. They weren’t the Global Occult
Coalition, for 343’s sake.
Why did Dr. Dan even want to terminate SCP-096
in the first place?
He’d tried to explain it to them again and
again, but his pleas had fallen on deaf ears.
In his mind, the impetus for destroying the
Shy Guy was terrifyingly clear. It was a monster
that killed anyone or anything that looked
at its face, even a photograph of it, even
a tiny collection of pixels. When its rage
state was induced, it seemed that nothing
would stop it. It would have an intuitive
psychic link to its victim, charge at them
at breakneck speed, and only find its zen
again once all of them were dead.
And if a picture of SCP-096 was leaked onto
the Internet, it would cause a chain reaction
that triggered an XK-Class End of the World
Scenario. There were plenty of creatures and
entities that the Foundation knew about that
could theoretically bring about the apocalypse,
but to him, 096 was the most realistic.
It preyed upon the inherent curiosity and
thirst for knowledge seeded in every human
heart. The same drive to simply Know that
led to the creation of the SCP Foundation
would be humanity’s doom in the face of
an SCP-096 outbreak, and if such a thing happened,
the Foundation would need to break the Masquerade
of secrecy to have any hope of saving humanity.
In his many feverish nightmares, Dr. Dan had
seen it all so clearly. The first photographs
of SCP-096’s face would be leaked online.
Perhaps a few hundred people across the globe
would look, in disparate enough locations
that it would be almost impossible for the
Foundation to detect and save all of them
as SCP-096 went on its bloody rampage. Of
course, as the image proliferated, as images
on the internet do, the purview of 096’s
violence would only grow. People across the
nation would start to take notice.
And soon after that, across the world.
“Mysterious creature causing mass casualties”
would be the headline on every news desk,
because why would anybody want to talk about
anything else? Perhaps some foolish reporters
would take video footage of the creature.
Everyone has a phone these days with high-definition
cameras, pictures would be taken and posted.
More and more and more of it would flood the
internet. Too many simultaneous moles for
even the SCP Foundation to whack. The news
would spread. Panic and hysteria would spread.
People wouldn’t even know what’s triggering
all this horror if the Foundation didn’t
go public and tell them that it was the pictures
that was killing everyone.
And by then, wouldn’t it already be too
late?
The antidote to fear is knowledge. It’s
why, when anything goes wrong, we’re refreshing
timelines and feeds and news websites for
any kind of information. And if you were told
an unstoppable monster was killing scores
of people and might be coming to a neighborhood
near you sometime soon, wouldn’t you want
a good look at it? Wouldn’t you want to
know your enemy, having no idea that the mere
act of knowing was what sealed your horrible
fate?
By Dr. Dan’s bleak estimations, if only
several million people died as a result of
this kind of scenario, it could be considered
a positive outcome.
He’d seen it all. But no matter how many
times he tried to articulate this to his superiors,
he wasn’t listened to. They didn’t take
him or the threat that SCP-096 posed seriously.
Every time he warned of the apocalyptic potential
of SCP-096, he was simply told to get back
to working on those goggles. It was why he
needed to give those naysayers a demonstration.
It was why a certain photograph needed to
show up in the home of a certain mountaineer.
It’s why all those people had to die. There
was no other way. The deaths of the civilians
and the researchers and the Mobile Task Force
members were, of course, regrettable, but
it was the only way to prevent the deaths
of so many more. They gave him what he wanted:
Permission to put this gangly time bomb in
the ground, even if the beast’s death was
inextricably tied to his own execution at
the hands of the very employers who authorized
him.
The world was full of funny little ironies
like that. Another one is that, even though
Dr. Dan now had the authorization and funding
to terminate SCP-096, he was discovering that
he lacked another important factor: The capability.
They’d tried incinerating it. Exposing it
to massive amounts of radiation. Exposing
it to an insane degree of kinetic trauma - the
equivalent of being hit by an out-of-control
bullet train. They’d tested every kind of
experimental, off-the-books weaponry they
had access to through various research projects.
Proton blasts. Lasers. High-intensity energy
beams. Nothing. Even when they fried off every
scrap of flesh on the monster’s body, its
unbreakable skeleton still remained, and in
what seemed like no time at all, it’d be
back in action.
Its very existence seemed to mock him.
A guard opened his cell door, staring disdainfully
at the disgraced researcher. That same guard
had slammed his head against a wall a month
earlier. One of his friends had apparently
been killed in the legendary 096 containment
breach that set this whole sordid thing in
motion.
“Up and at ‘em, scumbag,” he said in
a gruff, surly voice, training a handgun on
the Doctor he knew wouldn’t fight back.
“They need you in test chamber six.”
Dr. Dan allowed himself a small grin. Imperceptible
to the guard who clearly hated his guts. They’d
approved his 096 Vs 682 cross test. Marvelous.
To all the others, it would seem like just
one more entry in a long line of 682 cross
tests. He thought it darkly funny - In his
eyes, the Foundation had no hope of ever killing
SCP-682. Its defining quality was being impossible
to kill, and it didn’t present nearly the
threat to the entire world that 096 posed.
Their futile attempts to murder the lizard
were little more than a money sink to justify
the site’s exorbitant funding. But perhaps
he could turn this to his benefit. Maybe SCP-682
would hold the secret to actually killing
off his nemesis...
Within 30 hours, Dr. Dan had his disappointing
answer. Both anomalies had undeniably done
a real number on each other, and Dr. Dan did
take a kind of sick amusement in the mental
trauma that SCP-682 had induced in 096, but
ultimately it was all for nothing. 682 had
skinned 096 alive and melted off its flesh
with acid, but once again, that indestructible
skeleton stood firm.
This had been the 27th termination attempt
since the incident. The 27th failed termination
attempt, Dr. Dan mentally corrected himself.
096’s skeleton kept defeating them - Even
their most ardent attempts to penetrate the
bones and destroy the creature within had
failed. During a previous attempt, they’d
tried to access the brain by putting a diamond-hard
drill into its eye sockets. Of course, it
was the drill that actually broke, much to
Dr. Dan’s seemingly tireless frustration.
Needless to say, in the debriefing interview
with Dr. Carver, a researcher who once would
have considered him a colleague, he wasn’t
in high spirits. If he managed to kill this
thing, then he would always be the hero who
made a terrible sacrifice in order to save
many more lives. If he didn’t kill 096,
he was little more than the monster who murdered
all those innocent people for nothing.
Though you’d never hear him say it out loud.
If it wasn’t for that damnable indestructible
skeleton, this monster would be long dead
already. If only there was some way to break
the creature’s bones...
That’s when it hit him: SCP-173. The Sculpture.
A Site-19 icon often overlooked because of
its more “silent but deadly” style, but
undeniably one of the most frightening and
dangerous anomalies out there. It had racked
up a truly shocking body count since it was
first interred at Site-19 in 1993, one broken
neck at a time, and it’s one of the few
creatures out there that even the Hard to
Destroy Reptile himself is utterly terrified
of.
Perhaps a monster that practically had a PhD
in breaking bones would be the ideal candidate
to vandalize the Shy Guy’s vertebrae.
Once his proposal was greenlit for initial
testing, Dr. Dan arranged for the Shy Guy
- with a bag over his head, of course - to
be brought into a testing chamber with the
ever-stoic SCP-173. When all of the researchers
and guards were safely outside, all it took
was a single blink to make all of Dr. Dan’s
darkest dreams come true.
In the nanoseconds his eyes were closed, he
heard the most beautiful sounds in the world:
A loud, fleshy crunch, and a pained howl from
096. He opened his eyes to an equally wondrous
sight: 096 doubled over at an unnatural angle,
its spine snapped between the fourth and fifth
vertebrae, spinal fluid leaking down the creature’s
flank. That freaky little sculpture had done
it. It had actually damaged the integrity
of the Shy Guy’s skeleton.
It was at that moment that Dr. Dan knew he
could kill this thing.
Admittedly, there was a containment breach
shortly after that when the bag slipped off
of 096’s head and it charged through the
nearby steel wall, killing multiple people
before being subdued and recontained. But
when it comes to projects involving Dr. Dan,
a mere handful of innocent people being killed
sits comfortably within the acceptable margin
of error.
A day later, Dr. Dan was standing before a
crowded boardroom, with agents, researchers,
and even a few members of the O5 Council in
attendance. He explained his findings to them,
and the fact that, even more importantly,
they may have a way to bring the wretched
existence of 096 to an absolute halt.
His plans were approved. Not long after, he
was putting them into motion.
Dr. Dan was surrounded by researchers and
heavily armed guards as 173 was escorted into
the test chamber with a forklift. 096 was
there, still bagged. Off to the side was a
giant tub of hydrofluoric acid connected to
a hose and injector attachment. If this didn’t
work, nothing would.
Everyone stood back in a safe zone as 173
was released to do its thing. Crunch. Just
like the previous time, 096’s spine had
been successfully snapped. Spinal fluid dribbled
down its skin. Everyone had rushed into the
chamber - One group kept 173 isolated with
their stares. The other, headed by Dr. Dan,
prepared the acid injector and shoved it into
the breach in 096’s spine.
As the acid was pumped by the gallon into
096’s bones, the creature let out the most
horrifying wail. It kicked and bucked as more
acid was pumped in, melting those indestructible
bones from within. The creature even began
to vomit acid as it panicked, melting the
bag off of its own head. Some panicked and
averted their gaze. Dr. Dan didn’t.
He stared directly at the creature’s face
for the first time as it melted in front of
him with nothing short of pure elation. Had
he won? Had he actually won?
The creature let out a gurgling shriek and
the guards opened fire. Their bullets splattered
into the monster’s melting flesh and bones
as it hollered and shrieked. They didn’t
let up, firing up and down its body, spraying
it with white-hot lead. It began to melt and
bubble away, expanding into a great, gruesome
puddle on the floor beneath them. Dr. Dan
laughed like a madman.
Even as the guards grabbed him and dragged
him away from the foul-smelling, greasy mess,
bubbling with chemical life, he just kept
laughing. Even though he knew the death of
096 meant an equally swift death of his own,
it didn’t matter. It had all been for something.
The world was saved.
It was over. He’d finally won.
Close your eyes and pray for salvation: We’re
returning to the lanky, lethal, lad whose
rampages often result in legendary losses
of life. It’s SCP-096, the Shy Guy. Long-time
fans of the channel will no doubt know this
anomalous monster like the back of their hand
- after all, we have several videos on the
subject that are definitely worth checking
out sometime - but to get the full benefit
of today’s tale, we’ll do a quick refresh
for any potential newcomers in the audience.
Let’s start with the basics: The first thing
you’ll probably notice about 096 is its
daunting size and rather unusual bodily proportions.
While mostly humanoid in shape, the Shy Guy
has long, dangling arms that almost reach
the ground. Its body is thin and hairless,
with opaque, clear white pupil-less eyes and
a wide, gaping mouth. It’s a truly chilling
sight to behold, an abomination that conjures
up nightmares just to look at it… and we
mean that literally, you don’t want to look
at this thing, and we’ll get to why in a
moment.
SCP-096 doesn’t really do much during an
average day. Usually, this tall, spindly humanoid
entity will spend its downtime just aimlessly
pacing around in its containment cell, and
perhaps occasionally taking a nap. Pretty
relatable, right? Especially if you’ve been
trapped in your college dorm room during the
lockdown. But, if some unlucky soul should
dare to look at SCP-096 - specifically, its
horrible face - that’s when the monster
starts to act very differently.
Now, someone doesn’t have to be directly
looking at SCP-096 to make this happen, even
glancing at a blurry, distorted photo of it,
or watching security footage of the creature
can have the same deadly result. You see,
the moment the SCP-096’s face is seen, the
wiry monster will know.
When this happens, the creature suffers what
appears to be a psychological meltdown, covering
its face with its huge, claw-like hands and
weeping. Hence the nickname, Shy Guy. Utterly
inconsolable and suffering from extreme emotional
distress, eventually the creature will be
unable to take it anymore. Standing up, SCP-096
will then travel towards whoever dared to
look at it, using anomalous speeds to hunt
down the person that saw its face.
The Foundation has proven that it is unquestionably
impossible for anyone to hide from SCP-096.
Literally nothing can stand in its path as
it tracks down its victim; not walls or locked
doors, even being aboard a boat in the middle
of the ocean, or in a plane in mid-air can
prevent it from finding you. And when it does
find you, it’s not a pleasant sight. SCP-096
will kill the person that looked at it without
leaving any detectable trace on their body.
The monster is impervious to gunfire and all
other forms of conventional weaponry. It can’t
be killed or even so much as harmed. Even
if the Shy Guy is only seen as a tiny little
speck in a photograph, this will be enough
to trigger the creature’s relentless defense
mechanism. So, because of this, the SCP Foundation’s
only real way to keep the creature safely
locked up is in an airtight steel cube, with
no security cameras or surveillance tools
of any kind. All members of personnel are
reminded that they are to never, ever look
at it.
But what if they could? What if, somehow,
someone was able to neutralize SCP-096’s
anomalous abilities? Or was resistant to being
killed when the creature inevitably tracked
them down?
This is how the tale known as “Picture Perfect”
begins.
“What do you think boys? Is she a beauty
or what?” Doctor Clef proclaimed to a group
of his fellow high-ranking Foundation researchers.
The group looked in confusion and unease at
what Clef had been referring to, namely a
photograph that he’d just hung up on the
wall of his office.
A photo of what, though? Well, a four-foot
by five-foot picture of none other than SCP-096,
of course. Naturally, the other researchers
shared a mixture of shock and dismay at what
Clef had just done, as you would if one of
your co-workers hung up a photo of a creature
that could kill you just for looking at that
said photo. We’ve lost a number of staff
members from around the SCP Explained office
that exact same way.
Doctor Clef had long been one of the more
enigmatic and mysterious scientists working
at the Foundation, with the exception of the
elusive and infamous O5 Council. Alto Clef
was formerly an operative for the Global Occult
Coalition, as well as being known to be a
bit of a gun enthusiast and all-around crazy
wildcard. Clef earned his own brand of infamy
for his rumored practice of brutally “decommissioning”
dangerous SCPs, and you can probably guess
what we mean by that. He’s the Foundation’s
go-to executioner and a specialist in dealing
with reality-bending anomalies. Would you
expect any less from an ex-GOC?
Joining Clef in his office were the likes
of Doctor Jack Bright, another infamous Foundation
researcher. Doctor Bright, also known as SCP-963-2,
was assigned to conduct experiments on an
anomalous amulet, SCP-963, which resulted
in his death at the hands of SCP-076, Able.
However, anomalous properties of the amulet
gave Bright the ability to inhabit new bodies
after his death. Specifically, anyone who
also touches the amulet, which kills the host
and allows Bright to take control of their
body. While technically immortal, Doctor Bright
isn’t exactly stoked about that fact, often
seeking out death and wanting to know exactly
what it feels like.
Also present at the unveiling of Doctor Clef’s
photo of SCP-096 was his friendly rival, Doctor
Kondraki, While usually gruff and anti-social,
Kondraki is an expert in perception-based
anomalies, normally called upon by the Foundation
to photograph SCPs that would otherwise be
invisible or imperceivable. Doctor Cimmerian,
a member of the Foundation’s Ethics Committee,
was also in the room as Doctor Clef proudly
showed off his office’s latest decoration.
Perhaps the most outwardly strange researcher
in attendance was Kain “Pathos” Crow,
a scientist from the Foundation’s Research
Department who had been transformed into a
Labrador Retriever after an experiment that
needless to say, went a bit awry. Crow must
have been barking up the wrong tree on that
one.
Each of them expressed their reactions differently.
Deeply exasperated, Doctor Cimmerian shook
his head and began to question his recent
decision to stop drinking. Meanwhile, Doctor
Bright looked up at the painting with a bemused
tilting of his head. He wondered if SCP-096
would come to kill him, and if it did, would
it only do so once, or would the creature
try again and again each time that Bright
inhabited a new body? Perhaps in an attempt
to look away from the photo, Kain lowered
his head and covered his snout with a paw,
while Doctor Kondraki hung his head in deep
disappointment.
The only one among the group that seemed unaffected
by the sight of the SCP-096 photograph was
Doctor Charles Gears, another high-ranking
SCP Foundation scientist.
It was Gears who finally broke the uncomfortable
silence, asking Doctor Clef the one question
that had been on everyone’s minds: why?
Clef excitedly exclaimed that the photo was
meant to be in celebration of SCP-096 finally
having been neutralized, and according to
the scientist, they were free to look at the
creature’s “ugly mug” all they wanted.
The group stared in horror at the gaping mouth,
the screaming expression of the monster that
had killed so many people. Not one of them
shared in Doctor Clef’s enthusiasm.
Some, like Bright and Gears, simply argued
that the picture was creepy, while others
voiced far greater concerns. Kain argued that
putting up a photo of SCP-096 was in poor
taste, that it was massively disrespectful
to all the unwitting victims that the Shy
Guy had killed over the years. It was also
reckless and dangerous, Doctor Cimmerian added.
It had not yet been a full twenty four hours
since SCP-096’s apparent death, and if the
creature was somehow able to come back to
life, it could easily kill every researcher
in the office.
By showing them this so-called masterpiece,
Clef had put all his co-workers’ lives at
risk. He shrugged off their concerns of the
creature coming back to life, despite knowing
that was entirely possible. After all, it
wasn’t just anomalies and SCPs that could
defy death, most of the Foundation’s higher
ranked staff were also capable of the same.
Even some of the researchers in that very
room had died at least once. Doctor Clef claimed
that, should the worst happen and SCP-096
return to life, they could simply forget its
face with amnestics.
Clef claimed that they were now free of SCP-096’s
anomalous powers, thanks to the creature’s
termination. But the four men and one dog
in his office with him failed to share his
enthusiasm. The group then began debating
why the Foundation even needed to neutralize
SCP-096 in the first place, when its containment
purely hinged on nobody ever looking at the
creature.
“He could be contained by putting a sack
over his head,” Doctor Bright pointed out,
met with murmurs of agreement from the others.
“That’s where you’re wrong Jack. There
could be photos of him from before he was
contained, or someone could get a hold of
the photos we already have of him,” Doctor
Clef argued back. “If they did something
like hack Markiplier’s Youtube account and
put that photo on his homepage, it’d be
game over. The Shy Guy would breach containment
with millions of dash ones to kill all over
the world, and that kind of rampage would
guarantee he’d have cameras pointed on him
24/7. Exposure would grow exponentially until
the bastard slaughtered most of civilization.
As far as I'm concerned, he should have been
classified as Keter from the start.”
But Bright argued back, stating that the Foundation
had no real cause to kill SCP-096. They already
had a clear understanding that the Shy Guy’s
anomalous behaviors were only even triggered
by somebody observing it, and preventing that
from happening was pretty easy. Killing the
creature just seemed excessive, cruel even.
Cimmerian chimed in again, saying that killing
SCP-096 was something the Global Occult Coalition
would do, and the Foundation still hadn’t
learned all they could about 096. Could someone
survive looking at the creature if they were
in space, or another dimension? Now no one
would ever know.
On top of that, Doctor Gears pointed out that
the Foundation had no clue what SCP-096’s
exact origin was; where the creature had come
from, if it was the only one of its kind or
whether it was part of a species of similar
monsters. If more beings like the Shy Guy
could exist in the future, they could cause
a global catastrophe. But despite all the
points raised by his colleagues, Doctor Clef
didn’t want to hear any of what they had
to say.
“Alright, I hear what you're all saying,
but shut up, you're wrong! The Shy Guy was
a Sword of Damocles dangling over the whole
world, we killed him, and we're going to celebrate
that by doing the one thing we never could
while he was alive; looking at his face, each
and every day, for the rest of our lives,
so that we never forget what we've won and
could have lost…”
The four researchers and the one who had been
turned into a dog all took a moment to consider
Clef’s argument - more courtesy than he
had extended to them. They all looked up at
the haunting, grotesque face of SCP-096 once
more. As much as they protested the decision
to have the creature killed, each of them
secretly hoped it stayed neutralized, especially
now that Clef was using SCP-096’s photo
as an office decoration. If the creature ever
managed to come back, anyone that set foot
in Clef’s office and looked at the picture
was as good as dead.
Finally, Doctor Kondraki spoke up and threatened
to reassign Clef to one of the worst positions
imaginable: Critiquing first drafts of SCP
reports by junior researchers. For a moment,
Clef thought his rival was bluffing, but eventually
decided it was better to be safe than sorry.
As the gung-ho Foundation scientist begrudgingly
pulled the photo from his office wall, he
muttered to the group “None of you appreciate
post-modern art.”
A group of well-armed Mobile Task Force members
entered the containment chamber, armed to
the teeth. Some faced the ground, droplets
of sweat dripping onto their visors, some
wore Dr. Dan’s infamous SCRAMBLE goggles,
and one particularly brave member of personnel
wielded only a bag. The room they were currently
standing in was perhaps the most dangerous
place in the world.
Why?
Because it contained two terrifying titans
of the anomalous world: SCP-682, the infinitely
hateful Hard to Destroy Reptile, and SCP-096,
the Shy Guy, the ultimate mindless killing
machine. And if the very idea of having them
in the same place doesn’t feel risky enough,
this deadly duo had just spent 27 hours in
one of the most brutal brawls imaginable.
And incidentally, fights like this are exactly
why we’re here today. We cover a lot of
SCPs on this channel, and we’ve seen the
way some of the more dangerous anomalies out
there can tear their way through civilians
and trained Foundation MTF operatives with
ease. But how do they fare against monsters,
maniacs, and reality benders their own size?
With the help of the SCP Explained audience,
we’re going to explore theoretical fights
between some of the anomalous world’s biggest
badasses.
And who better to get this show on the road
than two of the most iconic and deadly monsters
that haunt the halls of a Foundation containment
site near you? The Hard to Destroy Reptile
and the Shy Guy are household names for anyone
familiar with the SCP Foundation, and before
we get to the gruesome results of their first
fight - and your theories about how a potential
rematch might play out - let’s get to know
the combat prowess of this pair of nasty customers.
What kind of damage are they capable of taking
and inflicting?
Spoiler Alert: It’s a hell of a lot.
In this corner, we have SCP-682: A monster
whose ability to survive seemingly anything
is only equaled by its terrible attitude toward
pretty much everyone and everything around
it. Though to be fair, you’d probably be
a little grumpy too if the SCP Foundation
was constantly trying to murder you in different
ways rather than just keeping you contained.
682’s basic offensive power set involves
impressive strength, speed, intelligence,
and the aid of its deadly fangs, claws, and
tail. However, 682 is considerably stronger
after it’s just survived and regenerated
from a termination attempt.
That’s because the true combat asset of
682 is and always has been its adaptability.
Specifically, if some kind of attack brings
682 into a state of near-death but doesn’t
finish the job, 682 will generally either
develop a perfect defense or counter-offensive
for that attack or somehow add a version of
the attack to its own arsenal.
This has ranged from super-pressurized jets
of its own blood, dangerously radioactive
banana beams fired out of its mouth, and even
an incapacitating laugher blast gained from
an encounter with the adorable SCP-999. It’s
an absolute swiss army knife of dangerous
anomalous powers and abilities - And if you
need any further proof of that, check out
our multiple videos on all the ludicrous failed
attempts to kill this nightmare lizard.
And in this corner, we’ve got SCP-096, the
Shy Guy. While 682 is freakishly adaptable,
in most situations, SCP-096 is pretty much
unstoppable. This long, gangly creep will
murder anyone who sees even the tiniest glimpse
of its face with such ferocity that not even
a trace of the body will remain. It does this
by entering what many call its “Rage State”,
activated by the sudden immense distress of
its face being seen. When it enters this state,
the SCP Foundation has only one prerogative:
Get themselves and anyone else out of its
way, because you will not stop this thing
until it’s killed its target.
All the SCP Foundation has ever been able
to do is wait until after the target has been
obliterated, and then come in to bag its head
when it enters its docile state. Almost nothing
else has even successfully slowed it down.
While they have been capable of damaging its
flesh, the monster’s skeleton seems to be
utterly indestructible, and its damaged flesh
has proven consistently able to grow back.
The monster seems to be immune to everything
from pain to cold, and moves at such a speed
that it’s pretty much impossible to escape
for long.
So when you factor in an indestructible body,
immense strength, immense speed, and an unstoppable
urge to kill anyone who sees its face, you’re
looking at a formidable opponent.
It’s only natural that the Foundation would
want to use 096 in their 682 cross tests,
so what exactly happened when the Mobile Task
Force entered the room after their first epic
battle? What did they find inside the chamber
in the grisly aftermath?
SCP-096 lay crumpled in the corner, wheezing,
scarred, covered in its own blood. SCP-682
was barely recognizable - SCP-096 had reduced
it to a quarter of its original size, the
rest having been utterly torn to shreds. Both
had narrowly survived the encounter, but it
was an epic battle neither of them would ever
forget - Though this was especially true for
SCP-096.
You see, as we alluded to earlier, SCP-682
is used to taking a kicking at this point.
It hasn’t ever truly been killed, but it’s
been beaten, eaten, burned, zapped, and smashed
within an inch of its life more times than
you can count. 096, on the other hand, was
not used to not being able to utterly eliminate
its prey. While it’s impossible to speculate
what’s going on inside SCP-096’s mind,
all evidence points towards getting a draw
in this battle, seriously damaging SCP-096’s
confidence.
Now, every time Foundation personnel tries
to bring 096 into 682’s containment chamber,
he begins crying and scratching at his own
face. Why? Is he scared of 682? Is he humiliated,
thinking of the fight he wasn’t able to
win? Or is the very idea of someone seeing
his face, and him not being able to immediately
kill them, just too unbearably stressful?
Seeing as the Shy Guy’s mouth is only good
for two things - and neither of them are talking
- we’ll never truly know. But either way,
it’s clear that 096 has no interest in a
rematch…
...But what if that changed?
What if 096 realized that it was wasting its
potential. It managed to get SCP-682 three-quarters
of the way to death last time, what could
stop it from getting that last quarter? Sure,
nothing has ever killed SCP-682 before, but
there’s a first time for everything, right?
Maybe 096 would have a Rocky-style training
montage, where he rebuilds his confidence
and becomes the underdog he was always meant
to be. He’d walk right up to that big, nasty
reptile, and give him the rematch of the century.
What would happen then?
Now, we give the floor to you, the loyal viewers
of SCP Explained. Here are some of your thoughts,
theories, and opinions on a potential historic
rematch between these two creeps.
Let’s get ready to rumble!
PinguWithAnAxe said, “If 682's adaptability
is based around his ability to develop countermeasures
to any damage inflicted (or in the case of
173, a countermeasure to the cause of said
damage) I imagine 682 would turn his skin
entirely reflective, causing 096 to see his
own face and the feedback loop would break
his mind.”
Interesting. Whether this would work is all
dependent on whether SCP-096 can actually
see, or if it is merely capable of psychically
intuiting when someone else sees its face.
If the latter is true, then this particular
adaptation wouldn’t do much good for SCP-682.
Random User said, “If this is after their
first cross test and they were forced to interact
again, they wouldn’t attempt to fight each
other. I feel like they’d form a truce and
take out the researchers on-site.”
This would be one of the worst-case scenarios.
Whether even the SCP Foundation could handle
a simultaneous 682 and 096 breach without
bringing in Hammer Down is an open question.
Ramon Voncken said, “Simple, after the first
encounter, when 096 stopped attacking 682,
682 will grow eyes that filter out 096s face
the next time.”
Organic SCRAMBLE goggles. Dr. Dan would be
fuming with jealousy.
Koopsader said, “I really want SCP-096 to
win so I’m sending him a blind personal
trainer so he can beat the snot out of SCP-682.”
This is exactly the kind of help SCP-096 needs.
He’s got the rage, endurance, and strength,
with a little help getting his form and technique
in order, he’d be an even more formidable
opponent.
Kytoe Ryu said, “I'd like to imagine 096,
after playing with 682 for so long, would
try to eat 682 in a vain attempt to kill it,
only to gain 682’s abilities, and vice versa.”
Either of these options would be horrifying.
SCP-096 with 682’s abilities, or 682 with
096’s abilities, would likely be a truly
perfect killing machine.
Autumn said, “What If they just shared a
nice cold drink while playing Mario Kart?
I’m sure 096 would be the white shy guy
character in every race.”
Personally, we love this idea, and we think
SCP-682 would go for Bowser.
Ibraheem Temur said, “682 would win eventually.
It’s way more intelligent, adaptive, and
overall malicious while 096 acts just on instinct.”
This is an undeniably good point. What 682
lacks in sheer savagery, it makes up for in
its ruthless, calculating intelligence. Could
this give it the edge over 096?
Monomoy Mukherjee said, “That fight will
be interesting because both of them now know
how they attack and what their attacks are.”
Nice segue. Due to the relatively mindless
nature of 096, as far as we’re aware, it’s
probably unable to learn from experience.
682, however, would have the advantage of
knowing how 096 operates in the second battle.
Devan Smith said, “As much as I'd like to
see how this would play out, I imagine 096
can't manage more than other SCP's have in
the past. Not to downplay him, but he might
need some extra friends to do a whole lot
more damage.”
It’s undeniable that going in with tag team
partners would better 096’s chances of taking
the lizard down. However, due to SCP-096’s
shyness, and tendency to kill everyone and
everything that looks at him, he doesn’t
have many friends looking to volunteer.
Nyan Tails said, “096 will cry in the corner
while 682 starts attacking it eventually it
gets confused that 096 isn't fighting back
after an hour and begins to adapt to it and
becomes docile forever.”
Look, while it’s unlikely that this would
happen, it’s certainly nice to imagine,
isn’t it?
Adam Britton said, “Narratively it needs
to conclude with a reason to never try it
again. So I'm going to say that 682 will telepathically
project the image of 096 into the site staff
or the entire human pychospace.”
Yikes. This is a possibility so terrifying
- And honestly, plausible - that it’s making
us regret wanting to see this rematch altogether.
Chaos Insurgency said, “I think 682 would
just think "For damn’s sake, just leave
me alone!"
Given he’s been through more termination
attempts than SCP-5031 can count on its fingers,
who could blame him for getting a little frustrated?
Michael Porter said, “I think that 682 and
096 would take each other to court for aggravated
assault against the other. Either one of them
will get sentenced to death and will unsurprisingly
not die or the 2 team up to kill the entire
courtroom and they walk out as a new serial
killing team.”
The real question is what kind of lawyers
would represent a pair of murderous, anomalous
monsters in court. Better call Saul.
Ari Wertman said, “Maybe if we try being
nice to them for once, we can offer them a
cup of tea and get them both a therapist.
682 will talk all his hate away and then realize
his wrongdoing and become an activist, and
096 would become very confident about his
face and become a model. There problem solved.”
Hey, when people strive towards self-improvement,
we’re all winners.
But we don’t know if we can say the same
for 682 and 096. Even if this rematch ever
did happen, perhaps it’d just be another
draw - An unstoppable force against an immovable
object. But other match-ups may be more clear-cut.
What kind of Vs battles would you like to
see us cover in the future? What SCPs would
you really love to see duke it out?
Let us know in the comments, and keep an eye
on the community posts, in order to throw
in your anomalous two cents for our next Vs
battle!
A streak of warm blood splattered across the
snow. Steam rose off it as it fizzled into
the ice crystals below. The severed leg it’d
just spurted from lay twitching only a few
inches away, torn clean off at the hip like
a broken Barbie doll. I think it might’ve
belonged to Arthur.
It wasn’t the first time I’d seen limbs
cut off. Hell, I’ve cut a few off myself
in my time. Don’t worry, I’m not a serial
killer - Just a med student. We all were.
I couldn’t say the same for the nightmare
we encountered up in the mountains that terrible
day.
The thin, cold air was laden with screams.
Mine, my friends’, and that...Thing’s.
All that it’d done to us. All that it was
still doing to us. And never once did it stop
shrieking and sobbing at the top of its lungs,
like it wasn’t even in control of its actions.
It didn’t want to do this. It just had to.
This violence was as inevitable as the sunset.
I screamed for Kyle. The snow was coming down
thick and fast, a curtain of burning, brilliant
white. I couldn’t see anyone, not even the
thing that was killing us. The water in my
eyes was starting to freeze up. It was cold.
So damn cold. What the hell was going on here?
Suddenly, a dark shape was moving towards
me through the wall of falling snow. It was
human. Vaguely. Moving towards me with frantic
speed. I tensed in anticipation when I then
saw Kyle emerging from the fog. He was splattered
with blood. His face red from screaming and
exertion. His eyes pleaded for help I couldn’t
give him. The horror caused my body to react
on auto-pilot with my eyes clamming closed
in terror, all I could do was open my mouth,
point with a shaking, frostbitten finger,
and force out a scream:
“Behind you!”
My words were carried off by the brutal mountain
winds, and with the sounds of mutilation ahead
of me, all I could imagine with eyes clamped
closed as I hit the frozen ground was a long,
grey arm emerging from the flurry behind Kyle,
its gnarled, clawed fingers reaching for his
head...
It was meant to be the vacation of a lifetime.
The kind of thing that you could only experience
once, but you’d never forget. We all thought,
in our own ways, that we’d look back on
the photos with misty eyes when we were all
old men. We didn’t know that, within a week
of arriving in Switzerland, whether any of
us would even make it to old age would suddenly
become an open question.
All four of us were doctors in training. Even
if you don’t know much about the profession,
it probably won’t surprise you to hear that
there’s a lot of practice and education
involved before you can ever really call yourself
a doctor without feeling like a fraud. You
need to ace your SATs, then slog through four
years of pre-med, another four years of medical
school, then the better part of a decade doing
your residency.
Seems a little much, I know, but believe me,
you don’t want some cowboy sticking his
hands in your chest cavity without all the
proper training.
But after we finally graduated from Harvard
Med, my friends and I decided that we needed
a break before the profession swallowed us
back up again. It was me, Brandon, Arthur,
and of course, Kyle. A lot of people I attended
class with would probably make a tidy sum
over the course of their medical careers.
Many of them would have made fine doctors.
But all of us knew that Kyle Molloy was more
than that - He was going to be a truly great
doctor.
He was smart, confident, driven, and had the
kind of smooth, effortless charm that made
you just feel safe around him. Where he went,
we followed. So naturally, when he suggested
we take a week-long sojourn in Switzerland,
the rest of us were all for it. We expected
an easy week of gourmet cheese, fine chocolate,
and the occasional jaunt down some old historic
districts. The exact kind of relaxing break
we needed after the soul-crushing pressure
of eight years studying the hallowed art of
medicine.
But of course, that wasn’t what Kyle had
planned for us. It turned out that his tastes
were far more extreme than what the rest of
us had in mind. His vision of a Swiss vacation
was mostly forest hikes, backcountry skiing,
snowboarding, and a little mountaineering
through the Swiss Alps. Apparently, he’d
spent a good portion of his childhood taking
Swiss vacations, and wanted to give us a little
slice of his personal paradise.
As someone who wasn’t exactly crazy about
heights or the cold, I can’t pretend I was
eager at first. But Kyle always found a way
of talking us back around.
It wasn’t long until we were booking our
tickets, then sitting on the plane, watching
the mountains get bigger through the porthole,
then our feet were on Swiss soil. It was a
beautiful country, and every bit as cold as
I feared. But soon enough, the cold would
be the absolute least of our worries.
As I glanced out over the breathtaking view
of the Alps, I had no idea of the terrible
nightmare lurking out there, hidden in the
dark spaces of those great rocks.
Something I learned in med school is that
human beings are kind of like fleshy time
bombs, their fuse ever-burning. When you reach
a certain age - and believe me, that age is
younger than you think - the assassin that
will one day sneak up from within and take
your life is already waiting inside you. The
cluster of malformed cells that will one day
turn into an inoperable malignant tumor. The
early whispers of the heart defect that gives
your ticker its planned obsolescence. The
microscopic ropes of defective genes that’ll
one day turn into Alzheimer’s or Parkinson’s.
In some cases, it’s just a matter of whether
you can catch it in time. But in just as many
cases, there really is nothing you can do.
You’re just waiting for it to get you.
After three days in Switzerland, we were suiting
up in our thick coats and climbing boots,
having no idea that the same principle applied
to us. Except this wasn’t that nasty little
assassin within - it was something outside.
Something that none of our skills or knowledge
could save us from. Something very old and
very dangerous. We were in fate’s hands
now, and sometimes, fate can be cruel.
Kyle was steaming ahead. He didn’t just
want us to ascend just any mountain peak,
he wanted us to attempt the Dufourspitze,
the highest peak of the Monte Rosa massif,
and the Alps as a whole. Kyle didn’t think
anything less than that would be a challenge.
After all, this was our once in a lifetime
vacation before we fully started our residency.
Didn’t we want to make this a truly remarkable
experience?
And because it was Kyle, none of us disagreed.
We started at the base of the Monte Rosa and
began to rise. Its lowest levels barely resembled
its frosty peak, over 4,600 feet above. We
took pictures of some of the wildlife: The
grazing Ibexes, Red Deer, and Chamois. Arthur
had bought a pamphlet on the local wildlife
back at a tourist-friendly mountain lodge
and took great joy in pointing out the different
creatures to us as he saw them. Brandon got
a good laugh about the fact there was a small
bird native to the area known as the Nuthatch.
Kyle forged ahead, telling tales of his prior
conquests.
The climb gradually transitioned from calm
to grueling as we ascended the mountain. I
could feel the blisters forming on my feet
as the cold first made my face sting, and
then go completely numb. Arthur, still consulting
his pamphlet, expressed excitement to see
a marmot when we finally reached 2000 feet
of elevation. Brandon started to complain
vocally, pouring himself a cup of coffee from
his thermos. Kyle chastised him for wimping
out already. After all, he said, the hardest
parts were yet to come.
Oh, if only he knew just how right he was...
We ascended further, feeling the air thinning
and our legs growing exhausted beneath us.
I started to resent Kyle as he forged on,
despite it all. How could he keep going when
the rest of us were faltering? It just wasn’t
fair. When the rest of us needed to take a
breather, we could feel the sting of his silent
judgment. He was always so damn perfect.
“We’re almost there,” he kept saying,
even though we all knew it wasn’t true.
Things took a turn during one of our rest
stops. We heard this strange noise, a kind
of pained wailing or keening. There was nothing
overtly menacing about it, but somehow, just
hearing that noise chilled me deeper than
any icy gust of mountain breeze. It’s difficult
to describe, but that terrible sobbing felt
like the purest distillation of true, bottomless
despair. I’ve never heard a more hopeless
and mournful noise.
Referring to his pamphlet again, Arthur speculated
that the noise could potentially be a Lynx.
Such creatures were apparently native to the
area, and their calls had a bizarrely human
quality to them. But somehow, deep down, I
knew this thing wasn’t human, and it wasn’t
an animal either. Whatever was making those
noises defied normal metrics of categorization.
To the surprise of no one, me least of all,
Kyle decided to lead the way in the direction
of that awful noise. Brandon and Arthur followed
him closely over the next tundra, getting
closer and closer to the sobbing. I hung back
a little further, gripped by this profound
sense of dread. I didn’t want to find out
what was making this noise - I knew, deep
in my guts, that if ever we found out what
was making that noise, something terrible
would happen.
And then, moments later, it did.
I heard Kyle gasp, for the first time ever.
The snow was blinding my view, and I couldn’t
make out what was actually happening, until
Arthur ran back toward my direction, and through
the blanket of white snow and with a voice
barely audible through his trembling said
there was a long grey creature. He said it
was naked and looked kind of human but definitely
was not. He turned back in a panic.
I could barely make out what my buddies were
doing ahead of me, but from the looks of it,
it seemed like Kyle was walking closer. Every
cell in my body was screaming, “No, no,
no!”
But by that point, it was already far too
late for all of us.
The creature began to turn. Perhaps it was
raw animal instinct that saved me, but I began
to turn, too, almost in unison, to look away
from the creature. I just knew that, whatever
this thing was, I couldn’t bear to see it.
And it was at that moment, as my body hit
the snow and I forced my eyes closed, that
the screaming began.
First, I could recognize the voices of Brandon,
Arthur, and Kyle screaming, and then something
worse. I can only assume it was the creature
itself, making the most terrible racket. Shrieking,
moaning, sobbing. And then...Ripping and tearing,
blood splattering across the snow. I just
cowered and shook against the ground as a
massacre unfolded behind me. I was listening
to my friends die, powerless.
Kyle, all his strength and direction stripped
away by terror, was snatched by the creature
as freezing, snowy wind gave it a cloak. I
heard Kyle scream, and then never heard anything
from him ever again. Soon enough, it was quiet
once more. No noise save for the howling wind
and the quiet sobbing of the abomination from
the snow.
I don’t know for sure why the creature spared
me, but part of me has always suspected that
it was because I never looked at it. I’ll
forever be darkly curious as to what that
monster truly looked like, but my friends
found out, and now I’d never see them again.
I wandered through the unforgiving cold for
hours, fully expecting that my frozen body
would be found in the Alps hours, days, or
even weeks later. I didn’t even care anymore.
The cold numbed my skin, my limbs, and my
thoughts.
At some point, a helicopter descended onto
the mountainside, full of men in tactical
gear with insignias I couldn’t recognize.
They wrapped me in an emergency blanket and
brought me in, telling me I required treatment.
It all turned to static as we fluttered away
from the mountainside, and all I could think
about was the monster that had taken my friends
from me.
It was still out there, waiting.
Now go check out “SCP-096 - Look at a Picture
of Shy Guy in Space? The Shy Guy Questions
and Theories” and “SCP-096 Shy Guy ESCAPE
- Incident 096-1-A Containment Breach” for
more on the Shy Guy that haunts all of our
dreams!